GET AFTERNOON EVERYONE. AND
WELCOME TO THIS ON THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE HEARING-
BUT DUE TO COVER NINETEEN FISCAL
DISTINCT IS STILL REQUIRED IN
THE HEARING ROOM FOR THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE. AND AS YOU PERCENT
AS WE PROCEED WITH THE WITNESS
AND PUBLIC COMMENT ON A MAKE
SURE WINNER STANDS ASSEMBLY HAS
RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING SO- PLEASE BE KIND
AND RESPECTFUL IN YOUR CONDUCT-
BUT WE- HAVE A FEW OPTIONS- FOR.
TESTIMONY TODAY THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
PERSON AS AS WE HAVE BEEN DOING-
IN OUR LABOR COMMITTEE SO FAR-
PUBLIC COMMENT IS IN PERSON.
FOUR EIGHT OR BY PHONE IF YOU'RE
KIND OF I PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK
YOU STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
A POSITION ON THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. A. L. B. R.
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV
THAT'S ILL BE OUR TIME TO SIMPLY
DOT CA DOT GOV. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING UP THE FEED. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACING QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE A BILL
FOR IMPLEMENTING ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMEDIAN NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
ONE OF MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP. I ALSO NOTE THAT AS
ALWAYS REXHEPI EXCEPT WOULDN'T
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AS WELL.
THROUGH THE POSITION. LETTER
PORT ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WE ALSO HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS
SET UP THAT YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL
US. YOUR TESTIMONY YOUR POSITION
ON ANY OF THE LEGISLATION BEFORE
US THE EMAIL IS A L. A. L. B. E.
R. DOT COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT
CA. DOT GOV AGAIN THAT'S ALE BR.
DOT COMMITTEE AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV. MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU
COULD TAKE ROLE IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM PLEASE. KALRA
HERE. KALRA HERE FLORIDA JONES
SAWYER REYES. SEYARTO HERE WORD. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
AND WE'LL START OFF BY ADOPTING
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE A
MOTION ABOUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM SECRETARY FOR
TAKE ROLE ON THE CONSENT JUST
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS AB TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ARAMBULA. AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
SIX BERMAN AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN CORREO AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR FLORA AND AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY FIVE THE COMMITTEE
BILL. THE MOTION- ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS- DO PASS CONSENT
TO APPROPRIATIONS IS AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR. AB TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE. MOTION DO PASS CONSENT TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY SIX. A MOTION DO PASS
CONSENT TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TWENTY SEVEN AB.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. KALRA
HI KALRA HI FLORA. JONES SAWYER
REYES ZERO HI SIRAT OF KALRA AYE
REYES AYE SEROTA AYE BOARD WARD
I WE. THE BILL ITSELF THE BILL
IS OUT AND WE'LL MOVE ON I'M
GONNA TAKE ITEM SEVENTEEN ABOUT
ORDER THAT'S AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WARD.
RIGHT. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS IT. ALL INTRODUCED THE BILL
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I LOVE THE
ENTHUSIASM OF RADIO MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS- WORKERS WHO SET UP
STAGING FOR LIVE EVENTS AT
ARENAS AROUND AN OUTDOOR VENUES
HE SERIOUS WORKPLACE HAZARDS
THEY HANDLE ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT
IN ALL WEATHER CONDITIONS
INCLUDING EXCESSIVE HEAT RAIN
AND WINDY CONDITIONS WORKING ON
READING AT GREAT HEIGHTS. AND
MUST DEAL WITH SETTING UP STAGES
OFTEN I'M I'M IN SERVICES SUCH
AS DAMP BROWN ST HOT ASPHALT
MANY OTHER SERVICES IS A HISTORY
OF ACCIDENTS INJURIES AND EVEN
FATALITIES WORKERS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SETTING UP AND BREAKING DOWN
THE FENCE SO EIGHTY SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
ENTERTAINMENT VENDORS WHO
CONTRACT FOR EVENTS AT STATE
OWNED OR OPERATED FACILITIES
WOULD CERTIFY. THAT ALL
EMPLOYEES COMPLETED THE FEDERAL
OSHA TEN WORKPLACE SAFETY COURSE
ALL HEADS OF DEPARTMENTS IN
LEEDS COMPLETE THE MORE ADVANCED
OSHA THIRTY SAFETY COURSE IN THE
HEADS OF DEPARTMENTS AND LEADING
AIDS AND RIGGING LIGHTING AND
PORTABLE POWER DISTRIBUTION
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE. AN
ATC P. OR MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
WORKERS HOW THE NECESSARY
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO
COMPLETE THEIR JOB SAFELY AND
NOT LIKE THE PRESENT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MISTER ANY
RAMEN RECENTLY RETIRED VICE
PRESIDENT AND C. P. AND TRAINING
DIRECTOR OF I'LL SEE LOCAL.
SIXTEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO. THANK
NAME IS HE SAID THAT HE RAN I AM
THE RETIRED BY SPEND TRAIN
DIRECTOR FOR MY TO SEE LOCAL
SIXTEEN SAM CISCO. I AM THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
SERVICES TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
WHICH GOVERNS TECHNOLOGY-
ENTERTAINMENT TECHNOLOGY. I AM
THE PAST PRESENT THE SAN MATTEO
CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL. AND I AM
AN OSHA OUTREACH INSTRUCTOR FOR
THE I. T. S. C. MAN I'D LIKE TO
DO- SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ATSC COUNCIL- MAGIC
IF YOU WILL THIRTY OR FORTY SEMI
TRUCKS. THAT SHOW UP AT THE
VENUE AT SIX O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING. THERE TO MEET AT A
HUNDRED FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY STATE CHANCE WHO HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THEY ARE IN THOSE
TRUCKS. ALONG WITH THE TRUCKS
COME A HANDFUL OF ROADIES WHO
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT'S IN THE
TRUCK AND THE PROCEDURE TO
FOLLOW. TWELVE HOURS LATER. A
SEVENTY FOOT. WIDE STAGE-
SEVENTY FOOT TALL STAGE HUNDRED
TWENTY FEET WIDE AND FORTY FEET
DEEP. IS ASSEMBLED WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF POUNDS HANGING OVER
THE ENTERTAINERS AND THE CREWS
HEADS. TOWERS OR ACTED IN THE
AUDIENCE. FOR FALL SPOTS AND FOR
SOUND. AND THERE ARE. LITERALLY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMPERES OF
ELECTRICITY RUN THROUGHOUT THE
VENUE. THESE WORKERS WILL WORK
TWELVE TO FOURTEEN HOURS A DAY
ON THE LOAD IN AND THEN OFTEN
COME BACK AFTER THE SHOW AT
MIDNIGHT FOR THE LOAD OUT WHICH
WILL LAST ANOTHER EIGHT TO TEN
HOURS. SIX AM THE NEXT MORNING
THE TRUCKS ARE LOADED AND THEY
DRIVE AWAY. THIS HAPPENS EVERY
DAY ALL OVER THE COUNTRY. IT'S
ALL DONE WITH AMAZING EFFICIENCY
AND GENERALLY IT'S DONE FAIRLY
SAFELY HOWEVER THERE BETTER
MISHAPS RESULTING IN SERIOUS
INJURIES AND OCCASIONAL
FATALITIES STRUCTURE TO FAIL
WHEN NOT PROPERLY INSTALLED
RIGORS OF FALL BECAUSE OF
IMPROPER USE OR LACK OF FALL
PROTECTION SYSTEMS. ENTERTAINERS
TWO CREWMEMBERS HAVE SUFFERED
ELECTRICAL SHOCK AND SOMETIMES
ELECTROCUTION. MERGES THE ACTION
PLANS ARE RARE AND IF SOMETIMES
NONEXISTENT THERE COUNTLESS NEAR
MISSES TO DO NOT GET REPORTED.
BECAUSE THE CREW IS AFRAID TO
SPEAK UP BECAUSE THEY'LL BE
BLACKBALLED WILL BE ALLOWED IN
THE NEXT DAY SEP MANY LIES
EVENTS ARE STE ARE. STAFFED BY
LABOR BROKERS WITH LITTLE OR NO
EXPERIENCE IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY THAT THEY DO NOT
USUALLY TRAINING INDIVIDUALS
THEY SEND THESE JOBS. THESE
PEOPLE TO THE JOBS AS REFERRALS
OFTEN AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
. THE OFTEN THE- THERE'S A
TASTIC MET LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROMOTING THE EVENTS IN SPITE OF
THE EFFORTS OF A PROMOTER OR THE
PRODUCTION MANAGERS TO EXPLAIN
TO THEM. THEY WILL HIRE WHOEVER
THEY CAN HIRE TO DO THIS WORK
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ESTÁ AND
EVENT SAFETY ALLIANCE HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR YEARS TO TRY TO
OVERCOME THESE. PROBLEMS BUT
THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE DONE IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE I COCHAIRED
THE ENTERTAINMENT TECHNICIAN
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THROUGH
ESTÁ AND WE HAVE SINCE- CREATED
FOR CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS FOR
ENTERTAINMENT RIGORS
ELECTRICIANS AND PORTABLE POWER
DISTRIBUTION TECHNICIANS. SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE IS ADDRESSED THESE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE CREWS WHO
DO THIS WORK AND EFFORT TO
ELIMINATE ACCIDENTS AND
FATALITIES IT WILL REQUIRE
PROMOTERS TO PUT ON LIVE EVENTS
AT PUBLIC VENUES. USING WORKERS
THE PROPER TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION THREE TCP PROGRAM
SUPPORT AND BUILT A SET A SAFETY
STANDARD ACROSS LIVE BEEN
INDUSTRY TO PROTECT WORKERS AND
THE PUBLIC. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. AGAIN JUST
**** YOU SEE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON BILL IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM. MODERATOR'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. YOUR
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE ARE YOU KIDDING
COMPUTER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
START WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT IN Q.
WE WILL START WITH LINE NUMBERS
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
REBECCA RHINE I AM THE NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LOCAL SIX
HUNDRED AND THE IATSE THE
INTERNATIONAL CINEMATOGRAPHERS
GUILD. AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. ABOUT
THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE. HI
RONNIE VALENTINE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR IATSE LOCAL
NUMBER THIRTY THREE LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT IN LOS ANGELES WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR VOCAL
LINE NUMBER TWENTY. HI EVERYONE
GOOD AFTERNOON BUT ON THE
CORNERS POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF
SAN DIEGO LOCAL ONE TWENTY TWO
WITH ACTING WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BIGELOW NEXT LINE TWENTY TWO. HI
MY NAME IS ARTI BOWL EARNING M.
WITH LOCAL SEVENTY FOUR FOR
WARDROBE UNION ARE FREE AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ITSELF.
THANK YOU. CAROLINA BURKE TWENTY
FOUR LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOURTH.
HI IT'S RICHARD DID THROW ITC
LOCAL ONE TWENTY TWO WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FIND OVER FORTY FOUR
. HELLO MY NAME'S TOBY BASED
BUSINESS AGENT OF LOCAL FORTY
FOUR AFFILIATED PROPERTY CRAFTS
WITH THE I. A. I REPRESENT OVER
THOUSAND SEVEN THOUSAND CRAFT
PERSONS AND I IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER SIXTEEN. HELLO
THIS IS JOANNE DESMOND I EIGHT
YEARS THE LOCAL SIXTEEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THE COALITION TEN
AND THIRTY TRAINING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN OUR LAST IN
SUPPORT IS LYING FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN ELLIS JUNIOR I'M THE
BUSINESS MANAGER AT A I GOT THE
LOCAL EIGHTY STUDIO PRINT PREP
SERVICE THAN THAT MEDICS WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NOW WE ARE FREE
TO HAVE SOMEBODY I'M SORRY MR WE
DO HAVE SOMEBODY THAT. CAN GET
UP HERE FROM. BY NUMBER.
NINETEEN HELLO MY NAME IS CARLOS
KODAMA INTERNATIONAL RATE FOR
THE I. P. C. NUMBER OF LOCAL ONE
TWENTY TO GO AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTY
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU- THIS
ONE OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB SEVENTY SEVENTY FIVE. BUT A
MODERATE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE. IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. PART
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE OPPOSITION. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP AS OF
RIGHT NOW YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK
YOU BUT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. MEDIA QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS. SECOND. RIGHT
RECETA CLOSER WORK THANK YOU ASH
PERCEPTUALLY REQUEST DRIVER
THANK THANK YOU THE MANCHESTER
TECH ROLL. ON AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
HI KALRA AYE FLORA AYE FLORA HI
JONES SAWYER REYES. REYES EYES
ZERO NO I WARD HI WARD I LEAVE.
THE BILL WAS UP. FEDERAL RESERVE
MADAM SECTOR MINING AS WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT A SIMILAR ALEX
LEE IS GOING TO DEMOCRATIC
VACANCY- THIS AFTERNOON I
BELIEVE HE DOES ANOTHER
COMMITTEES BECAUSE SHUFFLING
BETWEEN SOLAR PRICING AWHILE.
ALL RIGHT WE CAN MOVE ON BACK
INTO THE FILE ORDER ITEM ONE THE
SENATOR ROBERT RIVAS AB SIXTEEN
FORTY THREE AND YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES-
THIS LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY FORTY THREE SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE TAKE A
MORE HOLISTIC LOOK. AT THE
EFFECTS OF EXTREME HEAT HUMIDITY
ON CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS
BUSINESSES AND ECONOMY. AS WE
KNOW MANY IF NOT ALL THE
COMMUNITIES WE REPRESENT HAVE
EXPERIENCED OR ARE EXPERIENCING
THE WORSE THE IMPACTS FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE AND EXTREME HEAT.
IS ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
CONSEQUENCES OF CLIMATE CHANGE I
FORESEE OUR STATE IS NOT
ACCURATELY TRACKING THE FULL
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT. AS A
RESULT WERE UNABLE TO. PROVIDE
ADEQUATE- AND TARGETED POLICY
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
IT'S BEEN WELL REPORTED RECENTLY
THAT EXTREME HEAT EXPOSURE CAN
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
WORKPLACE INJURIES FOR INSTANCE
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT WORKERS
ARE FIVE TIMES AS LIKELY TO FALL
OFF OF LADDERS EXTREMELY HOT
DAYS. AT THE UP. REPORT TEACHER
IN OUR MISCLASSIFIED. WITHOUT
ACCURATE REPORTING AND TRACKING
OF SUCH IMPACTS WERE CURRENTLY
NOT IN A POSITION TO HELP IN
MITIGATE SOME OF THE EFFECTS OF
EXTREME HEAT. AND I SHOULD KNOW
THAT HE RELATED INJURIES ARE
ESTIMATED THECOPPER STATE
BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION PER YEAR. LIKE OTHER
LEGISLATIVE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR ON THIS
ISSUE SEEKING TO ELEVATE THE
VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM EXTREME
HEAT HERE IN OUR STATE. THIS
LEGISLATION SIX TWO THOUSAND BY
THREE COMMITTEE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO STUDY THE
EFFECTS OF EXTREME HEAT AND
HUMIDITY ON CALPERS WORKERS
BUSINESSES AND ECONOMY. IT'S A
DESERVE IT THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE STATEWIDE TRACKING ON
EXTREME HEAT AND HUMIDITY
RELATED ILLNESSES AND DEATHS AND
ALLOW THE STATE TO MORE
ACCURATELY ASSESS THE FULL
IMPACT WITH ME HERE TESTIFIES
AFTERNOON IS MICHAEL. LARA
DIRECTOR OF THE CLIMATE AND
ENERGY POLICY PROGRAM AT THE
STANFORD WOODS INSTITUTE. FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU MR
CHEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
AND I DIDN'T MEANT IS MAKING THE
HEARING WAS AFTER. THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW FOR UP TO
FOUR MISTER COMMENT TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS SPEYSIDE. THERE'S
JUST ONE WITNESS OBVIOUSLY THE
NEW- THEY CAN HAVE MORE LATITUDE
THERE BUT TO PLEASE TWO MINUTES
PER WHEN HIS PHARMACY SIDE.
THANKS VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA- MINES MICHAEL WARA
I AS A SUMMARY OF THIS SAID I
DIRECT CLIMB ENERGY POLICY
PROGRAM AT STANFORD WHERE. I
WORK ON CLIMATE MITIGATION AND
ADAPTATION ISSUES- AS PART AT
WORK I WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
MEMBERS OF OUR- MEDICAL SCHOOL
AND- MEDICAL RESEARCH SCIENTISTS
ON. ISSUES RELATED TO EXTREME
HEAT AND ILLNESSES RELATED TO
EXTREME HEAT. AND I JUST LIKE TO
SAY- THANK YOU READY TO TESTIFY
AND ALSO THAT THE COMMENTS I
MADE TODAY REFLECT MY VIEWS NOT
TO BE STANFORD- DESPITE OUR BEST
EFFORTS TO AND I STATE
pBEST EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO ADAPT WE'RE NOT
REDUCING EMISSIONS FAST ENOUGH
AND- UNFORTUNATELY IT'S LONG
BEEN CLEAR THAT GRADUALLY
WARMING CLIMATES ARE GONNA MAKE
EXTREME OF ANTS LIKE EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS EXTREME HUMIDITY
EVENTS MUCH MORE COMMON. THIS IS
PROBABLY THE MOST CERTAIN OF THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
BECAUSE AS WE SHIFT THE MEAN
TEMPERATURE GRADUALLY THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE THE ONE IN ONE
HUNDRED YEAR EVENT INTO A ONE IN
TEN YEAR EVENTS. THE ONE IN A
THOUSAND YEAR EVENT INTO A ONE
IN FIFTY YEAR EVENT. AND SO
EXTREME HEAT IMPACTS ARE LIKELY
WOULD INCREASE THROUGH TIME-
NEWER SCIENCE INDICATES THAT
MUCH HIGHER RATES OF WORKER
ACCIDENT AND INJURY- IN ADDITION
TO HEAT STRESS DURING TREATMENT
EVENTS ARE COMMON- ENDS. WE NEED
MUCH MORE STUDY- TO UNDERSTAND
BOTH HOW TO DETECT EXTREME HEAT
HOW TO- MEASURE ITS IMPACTS AND
THEN HOPEFULLY HOW TO PREVENT
THEM. A CRITICAL CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW IS. DEFENSE WHAT EXTREME
HEAT MEANS DEPENDS ON CONTEXT
DIFFERENT- DIFFERENT- TYPES OF
CLIMATES- CREATE DIFFERENT
CONTEXT WHICH CAN HE CAN OCCUR.
AVERAGE DAY IN SAN FRANCISCO-
ARE STRAIGHT AVERAGE AT AN
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS AND JUST GO
IS NOT GONNA MAKE SOMEONE FROM
BAKERSFIELD LAKE TWICE- AND SO.
WHAT WE NEED CRITICALLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
ITS IMPACT IS A COMMISSION TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT. HOW TO HELP
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WHICH
CURRENTLY HAVE WIDELY VARYING
DEFINITIONS OF THIS. SAFETY
ISSUE. TO CLARIFY WHAT
APPROPRIATE STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR DEFINING STREAM HE ARE SO
THAT THEN WE COULD DETECT. AND
WARN. AND MEASURE IMPACTS IN A
SYSTEMATIC WAY AND THAT'S NOT
CURRENTLY POSSIBLE I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT AB. SIXTEEN FORTY
THREE WOULD REALLY ENABLE- AND-
WITH THAT ALL CONCLUDE BY JUST
SAYING THAT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD BOTH FOR
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY. THIS
IS GONNA BE IMPORTANT ISSUE AT
LEVEL AS WELL IN CALIFORNIA A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN HELPING TO
DEFINE WHAT THE STANDARDS ARE
THAT ALLOW PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO KEEP OUR- WORK
FOR SAFE AND PRODUCTIVE AND
DRIVING THE ECONOMY FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM I
WOULD LIKETO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIXTEEN FORTY THREE. IF
NOT BELOW THE MODERATOR- IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES TO
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FORTY
THREE. YOUR SUPPORT AT EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN FORTY THREE IT IS ONE
NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. HERE'S WHY
NUMBER FIFTY CAN YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN HEARING NO RESPONSE
HERE WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY THREE.
NOTHING THE PHONES ANYWAY IN
OPPOSITION AB SIXTEEN FORTY
THREE. THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OF SIXTEEN FORTY
THREE YEARS ONE NINE ZERO. NO WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY ONE QUEUING UP
FOR OPPOSITION TO SWITCH THEIR-
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION FROM
SUMMER REYES SECONDED BY VICE
CHAIR FLORA. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OF ISRAEL LIKE TO
CLOSE- ONCE AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE- THIS AFTERNOON AND RESPECT
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
TAKE ROLE ON A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
THREE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA. RIGHT
KALRA AYE FLORA JONES SAWYER.
REYES SARAH. ZERO NOT LOADING
WARD WARD I LIED BILLS. IT'S
WILL PUT THAT BILL THE BILL
PLACED ON CALL AND MOVE ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH MORE TO THE NEXT ONE
WHICH IS COMMON TO. I AB TWENTY
EIGHTY TWO. ALSO WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN TO CHAIR AND SO THIS
LEGISLATION SOME THE BILL TWO
ZERO EIGHT TWO SIX TO CREATE A
PROGRAM FOR- CAL OSHA TO
CONTRACT WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
OUTREACH SERVICES FOR FARMING
AGRICULTURE WORKERS WHO SPEAK
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES. A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF PHARMACOLOGY
WORKERS SPEAK A IGITAL-
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES LIKE MAKES
DECAL IN SUPPORT THAT GOAL AND
DO NOT SPEAK READ OR WRITE
ENGLISH OR SPANISH. ACTUALLY THE
ONLY PROVIDE OUR REGION ENGLISH
AND SPANISH. AS A RESULT
FARMWORKERS WHO SPEAK- AN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE OFTEN LACK
ACCESS TO INFORMATION ON
CRITICAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO REPORT-
POSSIBLE WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS.
AND AS WE KNOW MANY FARMWORKERS
WHO SPEAK AN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE
OUR- RESIDENTS. DEPORTATION FOR
THEMSELVES OR FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER AND WITHOUT ACCESS
INFORMATION FROM A TRUSTED
MESSENGER AT THESE FARMWORKERS
ARE EVEN LESS LIKELY GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE. A REPORT ISSUED AT
THE WORKPLACE AGAIN THIS
LEGISLATION SEEKS TO REQUIRE CAL
OSHA CONTRACT WITH CBO'S TO
PROVIDE OUTREACH SERVICES
INCLUDING INTERPRETATION
SERVICES TO FARMWORKERS WHO
SPEAK INTO IT AN- INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGE. AT THIS MEASURE COULD
ALL OUT REACH CAL OSHA IS
OTHERWISE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE BY
LAW. PUTTING LIMITED TO
WORKPLACE RIGHTS HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE NINETEEN INFORMATION
AND HOW TO REPORT OF A POSSIBLE
WORKPLACE. SURE I WILL POST A
TAPE OF A DATA FROM THE ON SITE-
I IN FIVE YEARS CALLOW SHOP-
IT'S. SPECT IT BECAUSE IT
SHOULDN'T POST ON ITS INTERCEPT
ARE ON THE WEB IN. TO THE
LEGISLATURE EVALUATES- THE
IMPACT IS BY. WITH ME HERE JUST
. IS BUT NOT A SOLANO WITH THE
UP IN THE MIX DECAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT WITH THAT
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
SUMMER RIVAS YES PLEASE. UNDER
YOUR VALUABLE TIME THOUGH
NINETEEN FOR ANOTHER SOLANO- YES
SAID IN AND LANGUAGE- IT
WOULDN'T INCLUDE AN AFTERNOON
MEANING IS WHO ANOTHER SOLANO
AIMED I AND- SENOR ORGANIZER
WITH THEM IS THAT GOING TO CAN
THEM COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA CENTER
COSTS. MAKE UP LESS THE TABLET
IN DOESN'T WANT TO SUPPORT
ORGANIZE AND EMPOWER THE
INDIGENOUS MIGRANT COMMUNITY
FROM THE MEXICAN STATE OF OAXACA
AND GET LAID OFF INCLUDING THE
TECH BECAUSE SUPPORT GROWTH THEY
PUT US OF THE INDIGENOUS MY
COMMUNITY FACES UNIQUE
CHALLENGES INCLUDING LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AS MANY. AS B. R. AND
IS THERE IS THAT. THREE HISPANIC
- THEY DEEPER ROOT CULTURE
PLAQUE PRACTICES IN BELIEVES OFF
CREATE BERRIER AND ISOLATE THEM
FROM OR THEIR MORE IT'S THAT THE
IN THE- MORE THAN 50% OF OUR
RECORDS OUR RECORDS. IN
CALIFORNIA ALL INDIGENOUS
DOESN'T. I WANT FARMWORKERS FOR
EIGHT YEARS INDICT STRAWBERRY
INDUSTRY THING I TELL YOU WHAT I
SPEAK ENGLISH SPANISH. IN MY
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE STONE SAVVY
ALSO KNOWN AS MYSTICAL AS THE
FORMER FARM WORKER AND NOW AS A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WORKING WITH
THE INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY. I HAVE
A WEAKNESS FIRST CAME A LOT OF
THE INFORMATION YOU KNOW IT OLD
LANGUAGES. I SAW FROM MY ONLY
HOW ESSENTIAL IT WAS TO
UNDERSTAND OUR PRICING OUR
LANGUAGES S. R. A. FROM WORK- IT
WHAT'S CALLED A PRACTICE.
DESPITE BEING IT'S. EIGHT REMAIN
TO ONLY BE HEAVING THE SPINE. AS
THE CORE LARA. ALL THING AND
RELY ON BILLING WERE SPANISH HIM
IS THERE WORKERS TO PASS THE-
WHIMPER TO OTHER WERE. THIS IS
IN. AND DANGEROUS BECAUSE THERE
ARE MANY TECHNICAL WORK OR NAMES
ALTECH CHEMICALS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO INTERPRET IT THAT
INDIVIDUAL. INDIVIDUAL IS NOT A
TRAIN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER. IF THE INFORMATION
IS NOT GIVING CORITY IF BOATS
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR HEALTH
ARTERIES. AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO
WOULD GIVE GIVE COLOR SHED
OPPORTUNITY TO FOOD CONTRACT
WITH YOUR GRASS ROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ACCORDING TO
THE LAW ARE PREPARED TO GIVE THE
INFORMATION TO INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGE IS SPEAKING WORKERS. HI
THIS COLLABORATION WOULD HELP
GREATLY BECAUSE MANY WORKERS
ALREADY NORTH THEY ARE COMMUNITY
STATIONS ANG ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THE INFORMATION THEY ARE
RECEIVING COMES. AS IF IN THIRD
PLACE. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MORE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
PROVIDING IN CREATING A PROGRAM
THAT IS ACCESSIBLE BOTH
CULTURALLY. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR YES VOTE ON THE AV
AT TWENTY EIGHTY TWO PROPOSAL
THANK YOU DIVING IN THE- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM THAT WITH. THEIR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO
. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM. IF NOT MATTER
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO
. OUR IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE. ONE NINE ZERO
SIX ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY
ONE. HI THIS IS ABIGAIL ALVAREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUST THE COUNT
ABILITY TRANSACTION NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
PEOPLE HAD. SORRY CHAIRED MEMBER
SELECTED CASTRO DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STOCKPORT. THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER FIFTY SIX. HE HELLO
IT'S GREAT BUSINESS REPRESENTED
RIGHT. INSTRUCTS THANK YOU. AT
THE BOTTOM LINE OF TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON IS JANE
CAN OR WITH THE NATIONAL OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WELL I NUMBER FIFTY NINE.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IS NOT WORKING ON BEHALF
OF MY ORGANIZATION REPORT TWENTY
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. RED CLOVER TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE PLEASE CONTACT. HI
THIS IS DOCTOR THOUGHT I MIGHT
BE MINUTES- WHEN ASSEMBLY NOT
SOMETIME IN DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
I WILL HAVE EIGHT YEARS PERFECT
WORKING WITH THE DATA BY MARK
THAT DEEP LEGION AND THE CENTRAL
AND CENTRAL. AND WE ARE IN A
STRONG AND ALSO A QUICK FOR THE
BELT AND WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT
BOTH THAT. TWENTY EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU. WE NOT HAVE ANY
MARIN- TWENTY EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF IT IS OR ANYONE HE
IN OP. AB TWENTY EIGHTY TWO.
THERE'S ALL THIS OPPOSITION
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM- MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
TWO. YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY TWO IT IS
ONE NINE ZERO. OPPOSITION. ONE
NINE ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THEY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. HE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS. A SECOND.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH BRING THIS
FOR YOU THEN THE DAYS AS MUCH AS
WE WORK TO STRENGTHEN HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS IF THE WORKERS
ARE TRYING TO HELP DON'T KNOW
WHAT THOSE STANDARDS ARE ARE
MADE AWARE OF IT. REALLY JUST
SEVEN AMOUNTS. LITTLE OF ACTUAL
PROTECTION- AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS. THAT THE INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES AND I KNOW. THE
WITNESS SPOKE VERY WELL IN
REGARDS TO SOME OF THE IMAGES
LINES MEXICO BUT I THINK THIS
APPLIES. REVERSING A LOT MORE
CENTRAL AMERICAN MIGRANTS EVEN
SOME SOUTH AMERICAN MAGNUS OR-
THEIR OF VENTURING INTO INTO OUR
STATE DOING REALLY HARD WORK-
THAT SPEAK A VARIETY OF
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE
UNDERSTANDING IT DOES. COVER THE
BROADER RELIGIOUS LANGUAGES YES
. EXCELLENT SO I WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTIONWOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE SENATE RIVAS REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR AND RESPECT THAT'S
PRIVATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SECRETARY FOR TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON AB. TWENTY
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE. HELLO IS DO
PASSED TO PROVIDE. KALRA HI
KALRA I'VE- JONES SAWYER. REYES
ZERO. ZERO HI WORD. WARD I
BELIEVE THAT BILLS ON THE BILL
BE ON CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THE ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB TWO
ZERO ZERO THREE I BELIEVE- IN
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THERE'S SUMMER FONG
HAS NEVER PRESENTED BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. IT'S GOOD TO SEE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THOUSAND THREE IT
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO DEVELOP
MODEL CAREER PATHWAYS FOR SUCH A
WORKERS. THESE MODELS CAN THEN
BE ADOPTED BY LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS THANK YOU MAY
COLLEGES FOR THEIR OWN WORK AND
GUIDING A SUCH A WORKERS TOWARDS
HIGHER PRODUCTIVITY SINCE. AS
WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC MANY ESSENTIAL WORKERS
HAVE BEEN OVERWORKED UNDERPAID
ACCOUNTS EXPOSED TO COVER
NINETEEN THESE WORKERS DESERVE
RECOGNITION FOR ALL THEIR
EFFORTS AND PART OF RECOGNITION
CICHLID HELP ADVANCING THEIR
SKILL SETS THE HIGHROAD
OCCUPATIONS WITHIN THESE
INDUSTRIES. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THOUSAND THREE WITH DIRECT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD TO DEVELOP MODEL CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR CENTRAL WORKERS.
AND A BOY WERE FIRST START WITH
MONAKER PATHWAYS FOR LEASE FOR
SUCH A WORK ACT INSP MAY HAVE TO
. I COMPLETE THE RIGHT. A IS
BOARD WOULD DROP THIS MONTH
PATHWAY WITH COLOR AND FOR AND
LOCAL BUDGETS AND RELAY PARTNERS
. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE HAVE A WITNESS ON.
THE LOOK ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SUMMER FONG IS
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWO ZERO ZERO THREE. NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU GO TO THE
PHONES IF THEY WANT TO SUPPORT
AB TWO ZERO ZERO THREE. THE PART
OF EIGHTY. ZERO THREE ONE NINE
ZERO. SUPPORT. ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
QUEUING UP. MISTER NAZARIAN
MENDOZA HOUSING RAINY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION
- A MATTER MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. FOR IN
OPPOSITION IS ONE NINE ZERO.
OPPOSITION ONE BAND ZERO. AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE GIVING UP
MISTER CHAIR OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES SECOND BY
SOMEONE MEMBER WARD. NO FURTHER
COMMENT QUESTION- I JUST WANNA
THANK YOUR SERVER FONG THIS IS A
HI MAKING LEMONADE OUT OF LEMONS
REALITY IS A LOT ABOUT WORKERS
GOT THROWN INTO A REALLY
DIFFICULT STRESSFUL. OF THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT IS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IN THE AND TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO BUILD UPON
THAT IT ACTUALLY CREATE LONG
TERM HIGH ROAD EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- IS A GREAT IDEA
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THIS BILLBOARD AND- YOU MAY
CLOSE. THE GAP I'M SYSTEMOF
YOUR COMMENTS AND OTHER PLANT
THAT WE CAN TO CREATE HIS
MONIKER PATHWAYS IS SO CRITICAL
FOR THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA
SOBRE SUBJECTS FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAMS ACTIVITY TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON A. B. TWO ZERO ZERO
THREE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA. JONES SAWYER. REYES
HI REYES I ZERO. ZERO NOT VOTING
WARD LORD I LEAD ROLES ON THE
TABLE PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WE AWAIT THEIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
O MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
THE COMMITTEE. AND NOW FEDERAL
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE. GOING FROM ONE
EXTREME TO THE OTHER OF SOMEONE
PRESENTING FOR THE FIRST TIME TO
TEAR DROP FALLING DOWN MY CHEEK.
SOMEONE WHO MAY BE HIP HEARING.
HAHA I WANT TO SAY ABOUT THIS
IS. A SILVERSTONE AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU I'M NOT DEAD YET. WHAT IS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE IS A BILL TO GIVE
FARMWORKERS THE ABILITY TO VOTE
THE WAY THAT WE'RE USED TO
VOTING AND THAT IS- BY MAIL.
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE LABOR
RELATIONS ACT TO THE WEIGHTS
IT'S STRUCTURED. THERE ARE. ONLY
A WHAT'S ONLY ALLOWED IS TO HAVE
A POLLING PLACE AT POLLING
PLACES ON THE FACILITY OF THE
EMPLOYER AND FARMWORKERS ARE NOT
REALLY GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE ABOUT HOME VOTE
THEIR OWN CONSCIENCE THEIR OWN
WAY INOUTSIDE OF ALL OF THE
OTHER EXTERNAL INFLUENCES THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL IS DOING IS
CREATING A MAIL IN BALLOT.
OPTION FOR FARMWORKERS TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE IN IN UNION
ELECTIONS THOUGH STILL WAS
DETAILED LAST YEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR AND TAKING THAT
SERIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLSELY WITH THE GOVERNOR
LAST FALL AND NOW WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH THAT THEY RAISED. IN
TOWARDS THE EXPERTISE OF THE L.
R. B. FOR SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRY AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN. MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS FOR IT BUT ALSO PRESERVE THE
ABILITY OF FARMWORKERS TO HAVE
THE VOTE THAT DAY SO. WHAT IF
AND WITH ME AS A WITNESSES OF
WATER MARTINEZ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FED IT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF OUR BILL
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAY BEGIN
MISPERTON. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COULD WATER MARTINEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROPS AND IT'S PART OF THIS
BILL- OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS-
CALIFORNIA'S ENACTED MANY NEW
LAWS TO MAKE- REGISTERING TO
VOTE EASIER. A NEW LAWS THAT
GIVE PEOPLE MORE TIME AND MORE
WAYS TO VOTE. A NEW LAWS TO HELP
PEOPLE HELP OTHERS FILL OUT THE
BALLOT AS WELL AS NEW LAWS TO
LET PEOPLE GATHER BALLOTS AND
DELIVER THEM TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS. THOSE NEW LAWS NOT
ONLY STOP VOTER SUPPRESSION.
HE'S ALSO ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO VOTE. ARE THESE LAWS
OF. THAT WE CAN INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION WHILE KEEPING
ELECTIONS FAIR AND SECURE. THESE
NEW LAWS HAVE MADE IT EASIER TO
VOTE ON DIFFERENT DAYS AND IN
DIFFERENT PLACES REFLECTING HOW
PEOPLE LIVE AND WORK TODAY EVEN
DURING THE HEALTH PANDEMIC. THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS ACT
THE LAW THAT GIVES FARMWORKERS
THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE AND HAVE A
UNION. WAS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THAT WAS FORTY
SEVEN YEARS AGO. BACK THEN THE
ONLY WAY PEOPLE COULD VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT GOVERNOR OR MAYOR WAS
TO PHYSICALLY GO TO A POLLING
PLACE ON THE DAY OF THE
ELECTION. AND YOU HAVE TO BE
REGISTERED TO VOTE THIRTY DAYS
IN ADVANCE. BUT AS MENTIONED ALL
OF THAT HAS CHANGED OVER TIME.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO CHANGE
THE LAW GOVERNS. ELECTIONS AND
TO DO SO SURE IT FARMWORKERS ARE
NOT INTIMIDATED. OR THEIR VOTING
SUPPRESSED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
VOTING CHOICE ACT OF A. B. AB
TWENTY ONE. THREE DR. I THE
ROUTE IN SOME. AB. ONE EIGHTY
THREE. CHASSIS GRILL WITH THE S.
E. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER THAT'S GOT
YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
BROWN B. AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CHRIS MYERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SARA FLOCKS WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY THREE. THAT COULD
NOT. BECAUSE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY UP. YEAH AFTER FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY BUT PROCEED. WITH GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I MATTHEW ALONG
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL- WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE- THE
BILL- WE BELIEVE IS REALLY NOT
ABOUT JUST MAIL IN VOTING- IT
RESPECTFULLY AT THE LATEST
ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE THE SICK
WITHOUT ELECTION PROCESS. THAT
HAS LONG BEEN ESTABLISHED BY THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS ACT
THE SECRET BALLOT ITSELF SERVES
AS ONE OF THE ELEMENTS FOR THE
PART OF OUR FARMWORKERS TWELVE
FREE AND ON COURSE CHOICE IN
DECIDING TO VOTE EITHERFOR OR
AGAINST UNION REPRESENTATION. AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE
ELIMINATES A FARMWORKERS RIGHT
TO A SECRET BALLOT ELECTION THAT
IS FREE FROM ANY COERCION FROM A
PARTY THAT HAS A FINANCIAL
INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME OF THAT
ELECTION. THIS WAS RECOGNIZED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN'S VETO OF SB ONE
OH FOUR IN TWENTY ELEVEN
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S VETO
OF SB SEVENTY NINE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE AND MOST
RECENTLY BY GOVERNOR USES VETO
IT MAY BE SIX ONE SIX. LAST
YEAR. THIS GROUP TO NOTE THAT
WHEN THE AYLER WAS CREATED- UFW
FOUNDER CESAR CHAVEZ INSISTED
THAT THE ACT ENSURE. THAT THE
SECRET BATTLE ACTIONS ARE TO BE
EXCLUSIVE MEANS FOR REPRESENT
RECORD A RECOGNIZING- THE
FORMATION OF A UNION. THIS
ENSURES THAT FARMWORKERSMAKES
PRESS A TO PREFERENCE ON UNION
REPRESENTATION WITHOUT COERCION.
FROM EITHER THEIR EMPLOYER. OR
FROM THE UNION SEEKING TO BE THE
REPRESENTATIVE- I WOULD KNOW
WE'RE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE
BONDING REQUIREMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE BILL WHEN APPEALING A
MONETARY AWARD ORDER AT THE A.
L. R. B. AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
THREE REQUIRES THAT THIS APPEAL.
BOND FIVE. MMHM A CONDITION OF
RIGHT TO APPEAL IT. A THE BOARD
. THIS VIOLATES BASIC DUE
PROCESS BECAUSE IT BECAUSE IT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS THE BOARD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
EMPLOYER CAN MAKE AN APPEAL- THE
ELLERBEE IS NOT A NEUTRAL PARTY
IN THIS CONTEXT. AND HAS A
PREJUDICIAL INTEREST IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE APPEAL. THIS
LANGUAGE WAS ALSO FOUND IN AB
FIVE SIXTY ONE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN- THAT BILL WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. AND THANKS AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY THREE ON A LARGELY
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MR ALLEN
AND REEMPHASIZE THIS BILL HAS
BEEN VETOED BY THREE DIFFERENT
GOVERNORS THIS YEAR ABOUT
PROCESS HAS BEEN LONG SUPPORTED
BY THE NLRB AND OTHERS AND
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT IT IS THE MOST
ACCURATE REFLECTION OF EMPLOYEES
TRUE DESIRES WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO UNIONIZE IT IS FOR THAT
REASON THAT THE A. R. B. AND- WE
HAVE SPECIAL TOOLS IN PLACE
SPECIFICALLY TO ELIMINATE LAST
MINUTE PRESSURING AN
ELECTIONEERING. AND WE FEAR THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
PROTECTIONS I'M PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL HAVE CALLED SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS HYPERBOLIC
AND YET THERE ARE REPORTS
DOCUMENTED IN DECISIONS BY THE
ARB THE NRB AND- CIVIL COURTS
ABOUT THIS TYPE OF PERSON THAT
CAN OCCUR AGAIN ONE OF THE MOST
ALLEN- AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
AB TWENTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE-
FIRST MICROPHONE. NAME NAMES.
AND POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN- BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. IF NOT
MATTER MODERATOR IF WE COULD- GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE. WHERE DO WE DIDN'T
DO SUPPORT DONALD. WE CAN DO IT
ON YOUR KINDLE TOGETHER I
APOLOGIZE. OKAY SIR THANK YOU
APPLE SO IF YOU ARE A PROVIDER
OPPOSITION IT IS THE ONE ZER.
AND WE WILL TO MY NUMBER. SIXTY
BY NUMBER SIXTY TWO. HEY WE WERE
BOTH NEXT IN LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD BEEN AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CURTIS
PLAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BECTIVE A VOCAL LINE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALLISTER YOUNG
ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS GUILD
OF AMERICA WEST PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BILL THANK BY NUMBER
FIFTY ONE LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS THROUGH THE USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE IF THE
PRODUCERS REPRESENTING THREE
PROCESSORS AND OPPOSITION ITSELF
. THANK YOU. EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS START CANYON BIRD WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER. FIFTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANA HOW MANY CUT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL NOTICE
WITH THE FOUNDATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER SIXTY SIX BOB HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE
IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE TO BE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO
REMEMBER THE LEXUS CUSTOMER
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AT THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER FROM BOARD OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER FIFTY
ONE. BY NUMBER SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BRISCOE TO BOIL TO BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. BY NUMBER TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JANE CAN- WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WORDS FOR. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER THIRTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DEBORAH
GARVIE PHD IN A LABOR ECONOMIST
SPEAKING AT THE COURT OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY ONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF THE MILK PRODUCERS
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE AND WE
ALREADY DO HAVE A MOTION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE- I WANT TO THANK US IN
THE RESTORING OF FOR TAKING UP
THIS- RIGHTEOUS. OF FIGHT ONCE
AGAIN- AS- AS NOTED IN- THE
STAFF ANNOUNCES THE CEDAR POINT
NORTON RESTRICT A SIM FROM FOLKS
SAY WE'VE LONG STANDING
PROCESSES WHATEVER WITH THAT
TURNED EVERYTHING UPSIDE DOWN.
WHEN IT TOOK AWAY THE ABILITY-
TO HAVE DIRECT ACCESS TO HAVE A
CULTURAL WORK SITES THE WORKERS
AND SO THIS MAKES THIS BILL THAT
MUCH MORE. IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL I KNOW MANY OFUS ALL
BASES ARE CHAVEZ DAY NOT TOO
LONG AGO- WITH A LOT OF- VERY
NICE AND KIND WORDS AND THOSE
WORDS RING HOLLOW. WE DON'T
STAND BY OUR FARMWORKERS A
MISSILE WITH THAT- IT DOES IT IT
DOESN'T JOIN AYE RECOMMENDATION
SERVICED ON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD THANK YOU IT IT'S
VERYINTERESTING TO ME THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS. CONTINUING TO
HARP ON THE NOTION OF A SECRET
BALLOT WHEN. THE BALLOT THAT IS
MAILED TO OR PROVIDED TO
FARMWORKERS AND THEN TAKE IT
HOME TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISION
AT HOME AS WE DO WHEN WE'RE
VOTING HOW THAT'S NOT SECRET.
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT IS
BETWEEN PARKER AND THE A RP
MAILER VIA THIS BILL IS
OBLIGATED TO KEEP THAT BALLOT.
SECRETS SO THAT IS A COMPLETE
FABRICATION HERE ENDS. DAY
POINTING TO. BAD TACTICS ON
BEHALF OF THE UNION WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW FARMWORKERS.
BALLOTING HAPPENS NOW IT IS ON
THE GROWER SITE SUBJECT TO A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
AND COERCION AT THE GROWERS SAY
WHAT BETTER WAY THAN ALLOWING
FARMWORKERS TAKE ABOUT HOME
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY WANTED TO
MAIL IT IN NOT MAIL IT IN
OUTSIDE OF THE WATCH OF EVERYONE
ELSE. THIS IS A BILL THAT FOR
FARMWORKERS IT IS A MODERN BILL
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT GIVES
THEM THE ABILITY TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD IN ELECTION EITHER
WAY. HOWEVER THEY WANT TO DO IT
IT'S A SIMPLE MEASURE AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF A METAL. DETECTABLE
CALL VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA FLORA NO
JONES SAWYER REYES SIERRA WARD.
WARD I LEE HI LEE HIGH
PHILISTINE OKAY WELL PLEASE
AVAILABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
UP NEXT ITEM FIVE A. B. TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORK WHEN EVERY YEAR READY RIGHT. THANK YOU CHAIR KALRA VICE
CHAIR FLORENCE AND MEMBERS- OF
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS
LEGALIZED BOTH MEDICAL AND
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS USE.
EMPLOYEES CAN STILL BE
DISCRIMINATED GAYS AGAINST IN
THE WORKPLACE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS LEGAL
SUBSTANCE DURING THEIR DOWNTIME
. BUT WE CAN ALL AGREE NO ONE
SHOULD SHOW UP TO WORK HIGHER
REPAIR. THE WOULD MOST EMPLOYERS
CONDUCTED DRUG TESTS THEY
TYPICALLY SCREEN FOR THE
PRESENCE OF NON PSYCHOACTIVE
CANNABIS METABOLITES. WHAT ABOUT
YOUR SAID. OKAY THC IS THE
COMPOUND IN CANNABIS THE PRODUCE
A. S. PSYCHOACTIVE OF CAN MAKE
YOU HIGH. ALL RIGHT CERTAIN
CHEMICALS MAKE YOU HOT. THE
PROBLEM WITH USING A URINE TEST.
IS THAT IT CHEST NOT FOR THC BUT
FOR THINGS THAT ARE LEFT OVER
AFTER YOU HAVE SMOKED THC AND
YOU'RE DOWN. AND FOR PEOPLE WHO
SMOKE REGULARLY THIS COULD BE A
MONTH LATER OF WHICH CERTAINLY
DOESN'T TELL YOU WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE ABLE TO PERFORM THEIR
WORK- LU
WE TEST FOR THC. THEN WE KNOW
IT'S LIKE AN ALCOHOL TEST A
BLOOD ALCOHOL TEST. IF YOU USE
AN ORAL SWAB TEST FOR THC IT'S
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE TEST. AND
IF SOMEONE IS POSITIVE THEY
SHOULD NOT BE AT THE WORK PLACE
AND FRANKLY I DON'T THINK I KEEP
THEM ON THE WORK FORCE VERY LONG
- SO AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
WOULD ADDRESS THIS BY SAYING
THAT- YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY TEST
. TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT SOMEBODY
IS ABLE TO WORK ON THE JOB. AS
OPPOSED TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE SMOKED IN THE LAST MONTH
. IT CANNABIS IS LEGAL. BOTH
RECREATIONAL AND MEDICINAL- THIS
IS A BALLOT SOLUTION WILL
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES AND- IT WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE AS A
PROGRESSIVE LEADER ON CANNABIS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
STILL DAMAGED DEAL. ORINGER FROM
CALIFORNIA NORMAL AND JESSE
GREEN WALL FROM THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION AND MY GOOD
FRIEND- DEL WILL START THANK
YOU- THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRK RO WE'RE PROUD
TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT TO PROTECT WORKERS AND JOB
APPLICANTS FROM EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION FOR LEGAL OFF THE
JOB USE OF CANNABIS. ARE IN
PARTICULAR THIS BAND'S
DISCRIMINATORY URINE AND HAIR
METABOLITE TESTS WHICH HANDS ARE
MR CORKER'S EXPLAINED DON'T
DETECT ACTUAL IMPAIRMENT JOB
FITNESS BUT RATHER PAST USE OF
MARIJUANA DAYS OR WEEKS
PREVIOUSLY IN EFFECT URINE TESTS
ARE LIKE LOOKING THROUGH WORKERS
TRASH AND FIRING THEM EMPTY BEER. OR LIQUOR BOTTLES WERE FOUND.
LET ME SAY SOME STUDIES HAVE
FOUND THAT CANNABIS METABOLITES
ARE NOT AN EFFECTIVE WAY OF
PROTECTING JOB SAFETY NOT A
SINGLE FTA STUDIES HAS EVER FELT
THAT URINE TESTING IS EITHER
SAFE OR EFFECTIVE AT PREVENTING
WORKPLACE ACCIDENTS AND NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVE FOUND OTHERWISE
THAT WORKERSWHO TEST POSITIVE
FOR CANNABIS IN THERE YOUR HAVE
NO HIGHER RISK OF WORKPLACE
ACCIDENTS AND EVEN LOWER RISK IN
A COUPLE CASES. ARE LET ME BE
CLEAR AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
AND NO WAY COMPROMISES THE
ABILITY OF EMPLOYERS TO ASSURE A
SAFE DRUG FREE WORKPLACE BY
OTHER KINDS OF TESTS INCLUDING
IMPAIRMENT TESTS AUDITOR. CAPLET
BASED PERFORMANCE TEST WAR ORAL
FLUID AND BLOOD TESTS THAT
DETECT THE ACTUAL PRESENCE T. H.
C. FOR THE FEW HOURS WHEN USERS
ARE ACTUALLY UNDER THE
INFLUENCE. ORAL FLUID TESTS ARE
A LESS INVASIVE MORE ACCURATE
AND LESS COSTLY THAN URINE TESTS
AND HAVE BEEN FEDERALLY APPROVED
BY SAMPSON. AND FINALLY LET ME
SAY URINE TESTS ARE HIGHLY
OFFENSIVE INVASION OF WORKERS
PERSONAL BODILY PRIVACY I MEAN
TALK ABOUT COVERT MANDATES. TO
FREQUENTLY THESE TESTS ARE
MISUSED TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
UNPOPULAR WORKERS MINORITIES AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
DISCIPLINED FOR FAILING THEM
OVER TWENTY OTHER STATES HAVE
LAWS PROTECTING EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS OF LEGAL CANNABIS USERS
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
FOLLOW SUIT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JESSE GRAY WELL LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL HERE ON BEHALF OF
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS THOUSANDS OF HIM BUT WHO
WORK IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
UFCW IS PROUD TO SUPPORT AND
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK FOR
AUTHORING AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT WHICH CLARIFIES THAT AN
EMPLOYER MAY NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE OR A
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEE WHO
CONSUMES CANNABIS WHEN THEY ARE
NOT AT WORK. AND PROHIBITS THE
USE OF CANNABIS METABOLITES
TESTING OR OTHERWISE CALLED THE
HEARING TEST AND OUTDATED AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED TASK FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES EXCEPT THOSE WHO ARE
EXEMPTED UNDER FEDERAL LAW FOR
BEING A SAFETY SENSITIVE
POSITION. MEDICINAL AND
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS IS NOW
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER MANY
PATIENTS AND WORKERS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM USING CANNABIS
PRODUCTS OFF THE JOB FOR FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR CURRENT EMPLOYMENT
OR FINDING FUTURE EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE OF AN OUTDATED AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED METABOLITE
TEST. WHICH IS AN EFFECTIVE AT
DETECTING IMPAIRMENT AFTER
RECENT YEARS WORKERS INCLUDING
YOU HAVE SET UP MEMBERS HAVE
LONG SOUGHT ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
TREATMENT TO OPIOIDS AND OTHER
HARSH PRESCRIPTIONS OR
TREATMENTS FOR PAIN OR OTHER
MEDICAL CONDITIONS SUCH AS
CANCER. WE HAVE WORKERS WHO USED
CANNABIS OFF THE JOB FOR MEDICAL
AND MEDICAL PURPOSES. BUT WE'RE
DISCIPLINED OR TERMINATED FROM
THEIR EMPLOYMENT WHEN THEY WERE
NOT IMPAIRED OUTWARD. WORKERS
WHO HAVE HAD A WORKPLACE INJURY
A CURRENT LIKE FALLING OFF A
LADDER DENIED FROM WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS BECAUSE THEY
TESTED POSITIVE FOR CANNABIS.
USE DAYS OR WEEKS PRIOR AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT DOES NOT
LIMIT AN EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO
KEEP A SAFE AND HEALTHY
WORKPLACE AND ACTUALLY PROMOTE A
SAFE AND HEALTHY WORKPLACE THERE
ARE OTHER FORMS OF CANNABIS AND
IMPACT TESTING AVAILABLE TO
EMPLOYERS LIKE ORAL SWABS. THAT
DETECTIVE ON THE. DID THAT CAN.
USE OF CANNABIS HOURS. I DON'T.
THE TABLETS WHICH ATTACKS YOU
STAY OR WE PRIOR. AND NOT ACTUAL
ON SIGHT IMPAIRMENT WHILE AT
WORK. CALIFORNIA HERE USUALLY
LEADS THE WAY ON CANNABIS ACCESS
ISSUES IS LAGGING WHEN IT COMES
TO EMPLOYEE DISCRIMINATION FOR
MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS USE OFF THE JOB. WE
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO JOIN THE
TWENTY OTHER STATES AND
PROTECTING WORKERS BY VOTING YES
ON AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
BEHALF. THANK YOU. IS ANYONE ONE
ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE
OF COURSE- MICHAEL PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS EDWIN
FOR BONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NOT A MODERATOR OR IS
ANYONE ELSE OUT PLEASE ONE OF.
CAN WEARING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ABOUT A
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR HEART IT IS
ONE NINE ZERO. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR. I NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR YEAR OPEN. HEY WE
WILL BOTH THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
BRISTLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EIGHT
THREE- ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SERVERWORKS LEVINE
NUMBER FORTY TWO. SPINA
BERNARDINO EUROPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TURN NUMBER TWO
CHILD CENTERS ON BEHALF OF PDW
ON ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. SEVERAL
WEINBERG SIXTY FOUR. ONLY THE
WOMEN'S- IN COURT ON BEHALF THE
JUDGE POLICY ALLIANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN THE QUEUE ON THE
SWITCH CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SORRY
MAKE IT UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE MATURE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
AB TWO ONE EIGHT EIGHT AS A JOB
KILLER- OUR PARAMOUNT CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL I THINK THE
AUTHOR SHARES IT IS WORKPLACE
SAFETY- TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO SALIVA BASED TESTING
OR MARIJUANA USE OUTSIDE THE
WORKPLACE- I SHOULD ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE WE HAVE HERE DRAFT
AMENDED THE OFFICE OFFICE AND
HAD SOME INITIAL TALKS THERE
WERE HOPEFUL THAT THESE CAN BE
RESOLVED. AND AS A REMAINS WOULD
ALLOW FOR MORE TRANSITION
TOWARDS NON METABOLITE BASED
TESTING- WE HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
I THINK INCLUDE THOSE TALKS BUT
HOPEFULLY FOR- WITH A FRIEND OF
MINE THAT WOULD EMPHASIZE THE
TWO PIECES OF THIS BILL THAT
CAUSES THE GREATEST CONCERN- AND
REALLY PUSH IT TO THAT LEVEL
FIRST OF THE LOSS OF PRE
EMPLOYMENT DRUG TESTING. BECAUSE
THE BILL'S PRESENT LANGUAGE WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD MAKE
THE- PRE EMPLOYMENT DRUG TESTING
RELATED TO MARIJUANA SOMETHING
THAT EMPLOYERS COULD NOT PURSUE
THAT'S A HUGE CONCERN FOR US AND
NOTABLY WHAT'S- COPPED OUT IN
PROP SIXTY FOUR WHICH WAS A
NOTED THE PROVISION DID NOT
CHANGE QUOTE THE RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS A PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS TO MAINTAIN A DRUG AND
ALCOHOL FREE WILL PLACE.
SECONDARILY THE BILL HAS ITS
MECHANISM FOR CONTACT THE BILL
PLACES THE RELEVANT PROVISIONS
IN FEE HA WITH THE OFFICIAL USED
TO PROTECT AGAINST PROTECTED
CATEGORIES- YOU KNOW GRAYSKULL.
SEXUAL. CALGEL THAT SEE THAT- BY
THIS ISSUE IS THIS. SO FROM. BUT
AGAIN TO BE CLEAR ARKANSAS ABOUT
THIS BILL IS NOT THE USAGE
SALIVA BASED THAT'S KIND OF NOT
THE CORE ISSUE FOR US AS A
RESULT AT THIS TIME WE REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWO ONE
EIGHT AS A JOB KILLER BUT- ARE.
HOPEFUL FOR FUTURE TALKS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE HERE- IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALF
OF THE OFFICIAL POLICE GARAGES
OF LOS ANGELES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION A DOCTOR PARKS BILL.
THANK YOU. EVERY MISTER CHAIR
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS ARTICULATED BY
MR MUTURI THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WAS CHEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW WELL
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED THANKS. THANK YOU.
BUT A MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. ARE NOT
POSITION IT IS ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
ONE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THISIS
TRICKY DUE TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF THE PROJECT THE
PROCESSORS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HEY WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE MORE THAT GETS YOU
UP HERE TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
AGAIN IT IS ONE ZERO. AND NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ERIN AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER. SIXTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MEMBER
SABRINA LOCKHART FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION FROM
PARTICIPATION IN OPPOSITION DUE
TO SAFETY CONCERNS BUT
APPRECIATE CONVERSATION WITH THE
GIRLS AUTHOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER. THREE I
NUMBER. SIXTY THREE. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MARK
HUGHES YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COM YES PLEASE WELCOME
PLACE YOUR FLOOR THANK YOU CHAIR
THANK YOU DR COURT I AM CURIOUS-
IF THIS BILL IS LIKE SUCH A-
GOOD BILL AND FOR WORKERS AND
THE PROGRESSION WHITE. WHAT WAS
THE THOUGHT PROCESS ON EXEMPTING
THE TRADES THE BUILDING TRADES
OUT OF THIS- LET ME JUST CHECK
ON THAT. AFTER WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ARE WE FELT THIS WAS
THE MOST APPROPRIATE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF BOTH THE
BUILDING TRADES INDUSTRY AND
THEIR EMPLOYERS AFTER THAT YOU
SHOULD ASK THE CHAIR. BUT THAT
WAS HIS THAT WAS HIS DECISION.
AND WE AGREED. THE I NEVER
THOUGHT THAT I YES- BURKE YOU
GET. YEAH YOU GOT YOUR- THEY
HAVE A WONDERFUL FEDERAL LAW
THERE ARE SAY SENSE OF POSITION
THAT WAY THAT LEAST IT I'D
RATHER YOU KNOW OKAY. HOW THAT'S
YOUR CHECK WITH THE CHAIR. WELL
MISTER CHAIR I DIDN'T REALLY
MEAN TO STEP INTO A HORNET'S.
BUT- IT'S PARTNER THE BETTER DO
I DO WANT TO SAY AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE DEAL WITH A LOT AND
- IF IT IS GOOD. FOR ALL
INDUSTRIES AND THE EMPLOYEES-
AND THIS IS BY NO MEANS AN ISSUE
WITH MY RELATION WITH THE TRADE
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT- I
WOULDN'T I AM JUST CURIOUS LIKE
WHY EXAM TO THE ROUGHLY FOUR
FIFTY THOUSAND THREE MEMBERS
YEAH THE- APPRECIATE IT IS THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN GOING ON FOR. THIS IS A
BILL OR LEGISLATION SOME OF THIS
HAS BEEN REDUCED FROM NUMBER OF
YEARS INCLUDING BY OUR CURRENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA INTO
SEVERAL COURT TOOK UP THE MANTLE
BUT THE PERSON BEFORE AS THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF. VERY IN DEPTH
THE- NEGOTIATION DEBATE
CONVERSATION WITH THE TRADES-
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND
THERE WERE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
FIND THAT NEARLY CRAFTED
EXEMPTIONS AGAIN BECAUSE
THEY'VE- NEVER THE TRAYS AND
HAVING. HEAVY EQUIPMENT AND-
THINGS OF THAT NATURE- THAT IS
WHERE. THE EXEMPTION FOUND OUT
THEIR OTHER INDUSTRIES AND THEIR
SON THAT CAME HERE IN OPPOSITION
THAT WILL LIKE TO. WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR- AND DO SO. IN IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO MAKE ARGUMENTS FOR
THOSE SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS- THAT'S
THAT'S FINE BUT YOU KNOW THE-
AND SO- ULTIMATELY- THERE WAS AN
AGREEMENT OF BOTH WITH. LABOR
COMMITTEE AND THE LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE EMPLOYERS IN
THE FIELD AND IN THE INDUSTRY
ESSENTIALLY THE BUILDING TRADES
AND THEIR EMPLOYERS THAT HIRE
THEM THAT THEY BELIEVE THATALL
THE TIME SHOULD BE TAKEN AND SO
IT WAS IT WAS JUST A MATTER OF
ONE EMPLOYER OR WORK OR YOU KNOW
ONE TRADE WAS THE BUILDING
TRADES WITH THE EMPLOYERS THAT
THEY TRADITIONALLY WORK WITH
THAT AN AGREEMENT AT ALL THE
TEST SHOULD BE TAKEN SO. THIS IS
NOT SET BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS HAS BEEN MANY YEARS OF
CONVERSATION EFFORTS TO TRY TO
FIND- I HAVE IN A POSITION THAT
WORK FOR ALL SIDES AND WHAT THE
CONCLUSION WAS WITH THE
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS THE- IS IN
THOSE PARTICULAR IN THAT
PARTICULAR ROLE IN THOSE
PARTICULAR FEELS THEY PUT.
DECIDED MUTUALLY. THAT ALL THE
TESTS SHOULD BE APPLIED. I
APPRECIATE THAT I JUST I DO WANT
SAY THAT I WISH THAT AND I KNOW
DOCTOR CORK I WISH THAT WE AS A
LABOR COMMITTEE- IS IMPORTANT IS
THAT THERE'S LABOR IS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SOMETIMES A
WHICH WOULD GIVE THE SAME
DEFERENCE. TO OUR OTHER
INDUSTRIES AS WELL- WEATHERS THE
CHAMBER THE FARMER WILL THEY ALL
REPRESENT. A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
GROWERS- IN DIFFERENT BUSINESSES
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT NEEDS.
AND IF WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT A
POTATO MYSTERY AND CUT THEM OUT
OF SOMETHING. I THINK WE SHOULD
BE VERY CAUTIOUS AND LOOK INTO
OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT MIGHT HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME ISSUES WITH IT.
ON HOW THE IMPLEMENTED AS WELL
TO DOCTOR QUIRK I WOULD JUST-
AND PLEASE ENCOURAGE YOU HAS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO- IS
THE CHAIR STATED TO. HAVE THESE
OTHER OPPOSITION MEMBERS ENGAGE
WITH THIS TO TRY TO WORK WITH
THEM AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT A
SOLUTION THAT. IS NOT AS ROBUST
AS IT MAY PUT THAT I'M SEEING
RIGHT NOW SO I APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
LESS. WELL NEVER MIND. WHAT IF I
COULD HAVE ONE LAST THING AND-
CHIEF CONSULTANT IS. OUT IT'S A
LITTLE MORE CONTACTS. THEY HAVE
ANY CONTRACTS THAT HAVE THAT
WOULD BE IMPAIRED WITH PROJECT
OWNERS BECAUSE- THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT A CERTAIN PLAYERS. RIGHT NOW
THEY HAVE PROJECTS AND THEY
ALREADY HAVE THEIR OWN CONTRACTS
THAT DICTATE WHAT TESTING WILL
BE WHAT HAVE YOU AND BECAUSE OF
THAT. THIS BROAD BASED WILL
WOULD ALSO IMPEDED THOSE
CONTRACTS THEY HAVE CONTRACTS ON
STANDARDS OF WHAT. C. TO BE
REQUIRED IN A PARTICULAR SITE
THAT MAY BE VERY DIFFERENT
ANOTHER SIDE AS WELL. NO I
ABSOLUTE RESPECT THAT I THINK
THERE'S THOSE THOSE CONTRACTS GO
FURTHER AND OUTSIDE OF THE LABOR
REALM AS WELL AND I THINK WE
NEED TO. BE MINDFUL OF THAT AS
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I DO. TO
RELATE. I WANT TO ORDER ASSEMBLY
REPORT FOR BRING THIS BILL FORD
I THINK IT'S AN APT TO BUILD TO
BRING BRING BE VOTING ON AND
PASSING TODAY ON FOUR TWENTY.
WHERE MANY FOLKS WILL BE
ENJOYING LEGALIZED CANNABIS AND-
YOU KNOW THAT IS THE NEW LAW OF
THE LAND RIGHT AND WE SHOULD BE
PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR THEIR- NEW
LEGAL RIGHTS ENJOY RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA. N. AS WELL. EVEN YOUR
OPPOSITION- CONCEDED THAT THERE
ARE MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE MEASURES
OF WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE IS
IMPAIRED OR IN PEOPLE DOING
JOBS. IT DOESN'T INVOLVE URINE
TESTING SO I THINK ON THIS DAY
WHEN THERE'S SO MANY ACROSS NOT
JUST GOVERNMENT COUNTRY THEY'RE
GOING TO BE CELEBRATING TODAY
WITH. LEGALIZED RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS RIGHT NOW. THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOB OR FEAR OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET A JOB RIGHT NOW. AND
ESPECIALLY WITH SOMETHING THAT
LINGERS IN THE SYSTEM FOR SO
LONG AND HAS NO REAL IMPETUS ON
WHETHER NOT GET THE JOB SO.
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL RIGHT NOW
AND WE WILL PASS THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THE WHAT ELSE. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM THE SUMMER
LEASE OR SECOND. THANK OKAY THE
SECOND MISSILE- REYES. YEAH I'LL
JUST SAY THAT LOOK YOU KNOW THAT
THE TESTING. OF ANY SUBSTANCES.
SO WE SHOULD NEVER BE REGULATED
OR JUDGE OR AT LEAST WORKERS
FROM THE REGULATOR JUDGE ON
CONTACT WITH ARE NOT ON DUTY. IF
SOMEONE HAS A FEW DRINKS I
STARTED AT THE SHOP TO WORK ON A
MONDAY- THAT'S NOT REALLY
RELEVANT OR THAT AND FRANKLY THE
BOSSES. IT IS OTHER BUSINESS-
NOW THAT CANNABIS TO BE
LEGALIZED WE HAVE THE DISTANCE
WE HAD TO DE STIGMATIZE.
CANNABIS USE- AND I KNOW IT'S A
PROCESS A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
STILL GETTING USED TO THE IDEA.
THAT WE HAVE TO DE STIGMATIZE
WITH THE REALITY REALITY IS IT
WAS STIGMATIZED BASEBALL A LOT
OF PREJUDICE AND MISINFORMATION
OVER SO MANY. DECADES AND REALLY
GENERATIONS AND SO- I DO
APPRECIATE. THE CONTINUED
EFFORTS. OF ON THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH I KNOW IS TAKEN ARDUOUS
PATH BUT I THINK THAT WE'RE ON.
A POSITIVE PATH FORWARD IS- EVEN
HEARD FROM J. REPRESENTED THERE
IS STILL OPPORTUNITIES FOR. A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WHICH
IS GREAT BECAUSE WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO- WE WANT TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT- ULTIMATELY IT
REALLY IS ABOUT BRING EQUITY- IT
HAS SPACE THAT. ALLOWS WORKERS
TO BE FREE- FROM THE KIND OF THE
MICROSCOPE OF THE EMPLOYERS
ESPECIALLY WITH THINGS THEY DO-
OFF DUTY AND- THIS IS. IF THIS
IS THE LAST APPEAR BEFORE US I
WANT TO SAY IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
HAVING YOU. OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN THE LABOR COMMITTEE-
YOU ADDED SO MUCH TO THIS BODY
INTO THIS COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY
WITH LEGISLATION BROUGHT
FORWARD- AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. DR QUICK HAPPY FOR TWENTY. I
HAVE A FOUR TWENTY SHALL I
CLOSE. YES YEAH SO. FIRST OF ALL
WE DO NOT. WE DO NOT- PROHIBIT-
PRE EMPLOYMENT TESTING YOU JUST
HAVE TO USE THE SWAB NOT THE
URINE TEST NOW MY SON WAS- HAD
BEEN APPLICABLE AS ARE OFFERED A
JOB WITH PG&E WHICH ACCEPTED HE
THEN HAD TO DO THE PRE
EMPLOYMENT URINE TESTS AND HE
SAID WELL THAT GONNA HAVE TO NOT
SMOKE CANNABIS FOR A MONTH. AND
THEN HE STARTED SMOKING TO GET
TEST OF. THIS IS CLEARLY NOT A
GOOD WAY. TO ENSURE SAFETY ON
THE WORK PLACE IF YOU'RE GOING
TO ENSURE SAFETY ON THE
WORKPLACE YOU'VE GOT TO USE THAT
ARE ALL SPOT. ONE TIME URINE
TEST DOESN'T TELL YOU ANYTHING-
THE GAP WILL MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THE LEGISLATION THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT. NOW
WHAT THE CHAMBER DIDN'T SAY WHEN
THEY SAID WE WANTED IN A
DIFFERENT SECTION. WE HAVEN'T IN
THE SECTION HERE BECAUSE IT IS
EASIER TO ENFORCE THE LAW. OUR
IF ONLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
BRING A COURSE OF ACTION. AND
THEN WE HAVE A PROBLEM AND BY
PUTTING IT IN THE SECTION WE
HAVE WE WILL ALLOW WORK TO
REDRESS NOW IF THE CHAMBER WANTS
TO WORK WITH US AND THIS IS
REALLY WHY IT'S A JOB KILLER BY
THE WAY AND IT'S OKAY WE'RE GOOD
FRIENDS YOU CAN VOTE AGAINST IT
KELLY IT'S TO IT'S FINE. I YOU
KNOW I WAITED TEN YEARS TO DO A
JOB KILLER BILL. NO IT THIS IS
THE QUESTION QUESTION IN FOR. IF
A PERSON FEELS THAT THEY- ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY'VE USED CANNABIS OFF THE
JOB HAVE ALWAYS COME. THEN WHAT
IS THEIR BODIES THEIR REMEDY. IF
WE CAN FIND ANOTHER WAY TO FIND
OF MEMORY I THINK THE CHAMBER
CAN GO AWAY. I DON'T THINK IT'LL
BE A PROBLEM BECAUSE WE ARE
ALLOWING THAT PRE EMPLOYMENT
TESTS- BELIEVE ME I DIDN'T WANT
TO GIVE AN EXEMPTION TO THE
TRAITS BUT THEY SAID WE HAVE
THESE CONTRACTS THERE BLAH BLAH
BLAH. AND SO WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT
IT BUT- I THINK THOSE CONTRACTS
SHOULD CHANGE. I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
BUT GIVEN THE WAY THE CONTRACTS
ARE WRITTEN I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A CHOICE. WE DON'T WANT.
THERE IS SO MUCH WORRY WE ARE
TRANSITIONING. TO A CARBON FREE
ENVIRONMENT. AND PEOPLE IN THE
TRADESPEOPLE IN THE STEEL
WORKERS UNION TO WORK AT THE
REFINERIES ARE VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT THEIR JOBS AND IN FACT AT
THE DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION THE
HEAD OF THE TRADES. IS MIGHTILY
COMPLAINING THAT WE DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT THEIR JOBS SO WE HAVE TO
CARE ABOUT THEIR JOBS. IF I CAN
FIND ANOTHER WAY TO CHANGE
THINGS SO THAT THE TRADES
CONFINED THE SIX. POSSIBLE AND
THEY DON'T LOSE JOBS THEN I WILL
ASK FOR THEM TO CHANGE IT'LL
HAVE TO BE DONE BUT MY
SUCCESSOR. SO AT THE MOMENT
THERE JUST REALLY WASN'T ANY
CHOICE. SO THANKYOU VERY MUCH
DR CORK OF MADAM SECRETARY TO
COULD TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KALRA HI KALRA HI
FLORA FLORA NO JONES SAWYER
REYES. REYES I ZERO. SEYARTO NO
BOARD WARD I WEEK HI LEE I THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I THINK IT WENT. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM SEVEN. AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT SERVER
TAKING. VOIGTS THANKED THE
FOLLOW DR CORPORATE- LET ME JUST
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF- FOR ALL YOUR HELP ON THE
BILL WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT- AB
AT TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT IS A
BILL THAT REALLY TRIES TO ENSURE
THAT AS WE ARE GOING TO RETAIL
STORES AS WE GO INTO- GO ABOUT
OUR DAILY BUSINESS THAT WE CAN
DO SO FREE OF HARASSMENT. AND
FREE OF- ANY KIND OF VIOLENCE
WHAT WE WHAT IT DOES IS THAT IT
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO CREATE
A TRAINING FOR EMPLOYEES OF
LARGE BUSINESSES AND RETRAIN
WORKERS ON HOW TO RECOGNIZE
REPORT AND- PROPERLY RESPOND
INSENSITIVE COMMUNICATION IN
HARASSMENT AGAINST CUSTOMERS.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT ANY
WORKER AT ANY OF THESE COMPANIES
WOULD INTERVENE WE KNOW THAT
OFTEN TIMES THAT THEY ARE
INSTRUCTED NOT TO INTERVENE
FRANKLY- BUT WE DO ASK THAT-
THAT THIS IS A PROPOSED TO THE
CUSTOMERS DO KNOW THEIR RIGHTS
AND NO DOUBT. KNOW WHERE AND HOW
TO REPORT THESE INCIDENTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING- LASTLY- WE DO ASK THAT
DLPH CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO
PUBLICLY RECOGNIZE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY DOING A GOOD JOB SO
RATHER RATHER THAN. DO THE
OPPOSITE AND GO PENALIZE
BUSINESSES ONE WE GO AND
RECOGNIZE BUSINESSES- IT TO
REALLY ALMOST HAVE A YOU KNOW
GOOD HOUSE KEEPING SEAL OR A
SOME SORT OF AWARD SO THAT THEY
WOULD HELP INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESSES TO. DO DISCUSS WORK
WITH THAT- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT I HAVE CANDACE CHILL
HERE FROM THE API EQUIVALENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AT MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE- THANK YOU FOR
THE- TO TESTIFY TODAY AND FOR
YOUR COMMITTEES HELP. MY NAME IS
CANDACE CHAU I'M THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND COUNCIL
AT API EQUITY ALLIANCE A CO
FOUNDING PARTNER OF STOP ÁP I
HATE. I'M PLEASED TO TESTIFIED
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT A BILL AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AND
SPONSORED BY STOP ÁP I HATE.
THAT WOULD EXPANSIVELY RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS AT THE LARGE
BUSINESSES WHERE HATEINCIDENTS
OCCUR. SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC STOP AT I HATE HAS
RECEIVED NEARLY ELEVEN THOUSAND
REPORTS OF HATE INCIDENTS FROM
API'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
INCLUDING NEARLY FORTY ONE
HUNDRED REPORTS IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE. MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
THESE HATE INCIDENTS TAKE PLACE
AT BUSINESSES SUCH AS
RESTAURANTS. GROCERY STORES
RETAIL STORES CAFES GYMS AND GAS
STATIONS. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
WHAT API'S ARE EXPERIENCING HERE
ARE A COUPLE OF THEIR STORIES WORDS. AND MY
APOLOGIES IN ADVANCE FOR THE
PROFANITY. IN LOS ANGELES. I WAS
WAITING IN LINE AT A HOME
IMPROVEMENT STORE A MAN CUT IN
FRONT OF ME SO I MENTIONED THAT
THERE'S A LINE AND POINTED TO
THE LINE OF PEOPLE BEHIND ME. HE
BLEW UP AND STARTED VERBALLY
HARASSING ME. BY YELLING STUPID
**** CHANGE GO BACK TO THE
COUNTRY YOU CAME FROM. DO YOU
**** SPEAK ENGLISH. IN DAVIS I
WAS SHOPPING AT A STORE WITH MY
MASK ON. A WHITE OLDER MAN CAME
UP AND STARTED SCREAMING AT ME
SAYING. YOU NEED TO STAY TEN
FEET AWAY FROM ME YOU DISGUSTING
THAT EATING **** UNFORTUNATELY
WE KNOW THAT API'S ARE NOT ALONE
AND THAT BLACK AND HISPANIC
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALL EXPERIENCED
RACIALIZED HARASSMENT AT
BUSINESSES. AND WE KNOW THAT OUR
CURRENT CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS ARE
NOT ENOUGH. THAT'S WHY STOP
EIGHTY I HATE IS PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING ON AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GO TO A GROCERY STORE
PHARMACY OR OTHER BUSINESS
WITHOUT FEAR OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE GENDER OR OTHER PERSONAL
CHARACTERISTICS. WE HAD STOP AB
I HATE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TO
ENSURE THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES ARE NO
PLACE FOR HATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT. LEE ABOUT THEM
BEHALF OF CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION CO FOUNDERS
OF THE FACT ÁP I HATE COALITION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT A MATTER MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT. YOUR SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
FOUR FOUR EIGHT ONE NINE ZERO.
THAT ISN'T SUPPORT ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING APPEAR
TO BE JUST A MOMENT. WE WILL GO
THROUGH LINE. NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN GO I HAD. I THOUGHT I
NEEDS OF ELEMENTS AFTER- WE
VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
SO. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE BUT- HI THIS IS PRISCILLA
FONG WITH THE CENTER FOR ASIAN
AMERICAN AND ACTION YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE CUED UP HERE AS OF
NOW MISTER TAYLOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. THERE ARE NO PRIMERS YOU
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AS ANYONE IN THE ROOM I WOULD
LIKE TO. IN PUBLIC COMMON
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT. GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AT A MODERATOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT. ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION QUEUING UP AS OF NOW
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT OR
MOTIONS. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO RETAIN
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IS AN ISSUE OF
HIGH PRIORITY TO ALL OF US
BASICALLY THOSE OF US THEY'VE
GOT CAUCUS BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
SEEN PARTICULARLY IN RECENT
YEARS I ALSO APPRECIATE- YOUR
CLARITY IN AND NOT PUTTING AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON WORKERS
EMPLOYEES WILL BE ALREADY WE
ALSO KNOW HOW MUCH THEY- STRESS
AND PRESSURE THEY BEEN PUT
UNDER. DEALING WITH THE SIMILAR
KIND OF CONDUCT AS WAS OUTLINED
OF LAST COUPLE A COUPLE OF YEARS
WITH A PARTICULAR WITH THE MASS
MANDATE ALL THE OTHER ISSUES WE
DEALT WITH SO- I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE TIME ENERGY PUT
TO REALLY BINDING- THE RIGHT
BALANCE I APPRECIATE IT WAS LIKE
TO CLOSE. AGAIN WE THINK THIS IS
A GOOD FIRST STEP TOWARDS REALLY
ENSURING THAT ALL OF OUR RETAIL
OPERATIONS RETAIL BUSINESS BUT
IN PARTICULAR THE LARGE ONES-
REALLY TAKE THE FIRST STEP TO
ENSURING THAT THIS IS A FREE
ENVIRONMENT REALLY- WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH METACENTRIC IF WE CAN
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT. MOST IS
TO PASS APPROVE. KALRA HI KALRA
. LARA JONES. HI JONES SAWYER
AYE REYES. REYES SIZE ZERO ZERO
DO NOT VOTING WARD. WORDS I
LEAVE THIS SCRIPT THE BILL'S OUT
THANK YOU MUCH. BONTA ITEM. NINE
THIS IS AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A BILL
THAT FRANKLY IS THAT A LITTLE
BIT- LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WE SERVE ON WE
KNOW THAT MANY INDIVIDUALS FACE
BARRIERS FOR EMPLOYMENT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE. SO THEY DON'T
BECOME STATISTICS AS FAR AS
RECIDIVISM IN THIS BILL DOES
JUST THAT AND HELPS INDIVIDUALS
FACING BARRIERS FROM EMPLOYMENT
FOCUSING ON FORMERLY
INCARCERATED ARE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE HOMELESS HAVE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
IN TRADITIONAL WORKPLACES MANY
EMPLOYERS DO NOT PROVIDE IT
SPECIALIZED SUPPORT AND TRAINING
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES TO HELP THEM
SUCCEED. AS A RESULT EMPLOYERS
MAY TIMES ARE RELUCTANT TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THESE
CHALLENGES THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM AND LEADS TO THE
LINGERING UNDER EMPLOYMENT AS
WELL AS UNDERLYING ISSUES WITH
AGAIN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HOMELESSNESS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
WE KNOW WE DO HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
THAT ARE BUSINESSES THAT FILL
THE GAPS AND UP EMPLOYEE AND
HELP INDIVIDUALS GAIN
EMPLOYMENT. PROVIDING WHAT THEY
NEED ALONG THE WAY. BILL WOULD
BASICALLY- HELP CREATE A
STATEWIDE NETWORK AND MODEL
AFTER SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS LIKE
THE RISE PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES.
PROVIDE FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WERE WORKING
CONCURRENTLY THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS ALLOW THESE GROUPS TO
HIRED SUPPORT MORE PEOPLE TO
HAVE A MEANINGFUL AND GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT- WITH ME. TODAY ARE
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK
EXTENSIVELY IN THIS FIELD. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU ARE MR CHAIRMAN
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLA JAVITS I'M A SENIOR
ADVISOR TO THE CEO OF READ UP
THE ROBERTS ENTERPRISE
DEVELOPMENT FUND WHERE I WAS
PREVIOUSLY THE CEO FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS READ F. IS THE SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY. READ OF
HIS A CALIFORNIA GROWN NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING THE
GROWING FIELD OF EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES THESE ARE
SPECIAL BUSINESSES THAT
EXPLICITLY INCORPORATE PAID
EMPLOYMENT WORKFORCE TRAINING
AND HUMAN SERVICES THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
ON THE SIDELINES OF THE ECONOMY
. TO OVERCOME THE REAL IMPLORES
HIRE THEM DUE TO THE IMPACT OF
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM HOMELESSNESS
HOUSING AND SECURITY THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM FAMILY VIOLENCE.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN READ
OF HIS PROVIDED CAPITAL AND
ADVISORY SERVICES TO ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
OF TRAINED AND EMPLOYED OVER
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE STATEWIDE ALMOST
HALF OF THOSE FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE. THESE BUSINESSES HELP
GOVERNMENT DOLLARS FURTHER WHILE
STIMULATING THE ECONOMY AND
UPLIFTING EQUITY NEARLY 75% OF
THE SECTORS OF BOYS ARE JUSTICE
IMPACTED AND 71% ARE BLACK OR
LEFT. INDEPENDENT RESEARCH-
FOUGHT THE WORK EXPERIENCE AND
SUPPORTS THESE BUSINESSES
PROVIDE DOUBLE JOB RETENTION
INCREASED WAGES AND INCOMES
IMPROVE HOUSING STABILITY. SOME
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY IS PATH
BREAKING LEGISLATION TO TARGET
FUNDING AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
AND UNDERSERVED BUSINESS GROUP.
HELLO HELP IN YOU GREAT I'M WITH
GOVERNMENT RESPONSES SERVICES
AND JOB PRIVATE SECTOR. TO X.
EIGHT ECONOMIC ONLY AS A MEMBER
OF THE GOVERNOR. TO CREATE A NEW
SOCIAL COMPACT FOR WORKING
WORKERS. TWENTY SIX SEVENTY IS
AN INITIAL STEP TOWARD
IMPLEMENTING ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE FINAL
REPORT TO EXTEND THIS FINANCIAL
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISE
PLEASE JOIN US IN SUPPORTING AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY AND VOTE HI
FOR INVESTING IN THE GROWTH OF
BUSINESSES. PREVENTING AND
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS AND CART
GEN AND ENGAGING NEW TALENT
POOLS IN BUILDING AN INCLUSIVE
MORE EQUITABLE ECONOMY. AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE WOMAN THEY
GIVE YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
DISTINGUISHED. MY NAME IS ANA.
ABOUT A BILL AND I'M THE WORK
WAS DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR A GREAT
ALTERNATIVES. SAN WE ARE
EMPLOYMENT SO ENTERPRISE IN OUR
MISSION IS TO BUILD COME POWER
SOLUTIONS TO ADVANCE ECONOMIC
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY. WE PROVIDE A
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE FOR MORE
THAN FORTY TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS TO HELP MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED TRAINEES A
TRANSITIONAL EMPLOYEES. SECURE
EMPLOYMENT IN SOLAR AND RELATED
INDUSTRIES- AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY. ALREADY IF
ORDER ROBERTS ENTERPRISE
DEVELOPMENT FUND BEGAN WORKING
WITH US A GREAT ALTERNATIVES IN
LA IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. PROVIDING
A GRAND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT. TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE. IN TWENTY TWENTY
RETALIATES DOES FULLY APPLIED TO
BE PART OF THE RED OF ROCOR
GROWTH PORTFOLIO. A THREE YEAR
GRANT PROVIDING UNRESTRICTED
FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE RESULTS
INCREASED OUR REVENUE AND
EXPONENTIAL GROWTH THAT WILL
HAVE A LASTING IMPACT ON THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH THE
HIGHEST BIDDERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INCLUDING RETURNING CITIZENS OF
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED OPPORTUNITY
pTWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR WE LOOK I'M A CONTRACTOR
VALLEY RISE THE REGIONALIST
INITIATIVE FOR SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES. AND INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES.
IF LA RAZA DESIGNED BROWN
TRANSITIONAL EMPLOYEES AND
TRANSITIONAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
HIGHEST BERRIES TO IMPLEMENT.
PARTICULARLY THOSE ARE STABLY
HOUSED AND THOSE FACING
HOMELESSNESS RUDY CARD IS A
GREAT EMPLOYEE WHO CAME TO L. A.
RISES NOW EQUIPPED TO DO ON THE
ROOF CONSTRUCTION WORK AND
SUBSEQUENT QUICKLY WAS HIRED ON
FULL TIME. FOR A YEAR AS A SOFT
CORE CONSTRUCTION GREAT
ALTERNATIVES WHAT OUT GREETED
RUDY MAY HAVE NEVER REALIZED HIS
FULL POTENTIAL NOT ONLY IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY SPACE. ALSO ON THE
LIST MARKET HELLO. THANK AND ASK
YOU TO YEAH WILL. LIE RUDY- IN
VOTE IN FAVOR OF TWO SIX. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
PLEASE- PROSPECT FONG THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON MARK THE
RANCHER PRESIDENCY OF CHRISTMAS
A LOS ANGELES BASED NONPROFIT
WERE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MARIA CAN CURRENT CEO OF
RUNOFF ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBER
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER ROWE
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA GOODWILL INDUSTRIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY. YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY IT'S ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE
SIXTY SEVEN. NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M NOT BUT I BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ESCALATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE. WHAT IS THE BIG
DINNER WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE CUED UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
AS ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO. A. TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY. THE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY. OUR
OPPOSITION IS ONE NINE ZERO. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR CUED
UP. BUT HAD. ACTUALLY THE FOR
SUPPORT IT WASN'T GOING THROUGH
BUT ONLY IF YOU LOOK ON BEHALF
OF THE FLIGHT THE GREEN YORK
MARKET WORK IN CITIES PARTED
EQUITY AND THE U. S. FEDERATION
OF WORKER COOPERATIVES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE CUED UP MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTIONS. WHO MOTIONS. MORE. TO
PICK IS THERE A SECOND. LOLS
AFTERNOON ALL RIGHT- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OR I WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISS
JOHNSON I ACTUALLY SERVED ON THE
FUTURE RECOGNITION TOGETHER SO-
THIS WAS A BIG TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION DURING THE COURSE
THE COMMISSION I REALLY
APPRECIATE HER WORK AND HER
EXPERTISE A SHOPPER DURING THE
COMMISSION TO SEE THAT WORK.
BEING DEMONSTRATED HERE NOW
THROUGH HIS BILL- THE
FURTHERANCE OF THAT WORK I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT IS ALL BUT
I WAS A PUBLIC DEFENDER. I WAS
SPENDING COUNTLESS TIMES HOURS
TRYING TO HELP OUR CLIENTS GET
GET EMPLOYMENT GET THE- THEY
WERE DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT AND
YET ALL THEY WERE RUNNING INTO
WERE DEAD ENDS AND SO THIS IS
REALLY NOT JUST A THE TOP I JUST
TRANSITION I CALL THE JUSTICE
TRANSITION. REALLY THAT GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY- YOU KNOW GO BACK
INTO OUR ECONOMY BACK ON THEIR
FEET IN A VERY PRODUCTIVE
MANNERS SO WITH THAT I REALLY
LIKE CLOSE. YEAH YOU KNOW YOU
YOU SAID IT WELL IF YEARS AGO I
WAS IN THIS COMMITTEE FOCUSING
ON BANNING THE BOX AS FAR AS
EMPLOYMENT IN THAT IT TO THE
PUZZLE AND LOCAL RECORD LOW
IMPLEMENTING CAT ARE YOU CAN
COUNTRY STATE. THE STILL TWO
PEOPLE ARE LEFT BEHIND CAN'T-
GET JOBS AND CONVERSELY WE HAVE
LOTS OF EMPLOYERS AND THE PEOPLE
TO WORK WE HAVE A PEOPLE PROBLEM
IN SOME OF THE SKILLS IT.
PRESSED IN IN THREE SCHOOL THEN
OKAY CENTERS AND THE IS THE GO
BETWEEN CAN HELP I SAW. THE. FOR
READ FOR THE PEOPLE OF
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE LEFT BEHIND
SO WITH THAT AS YOU RIGHT BUT
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SET
FOR TAKE THE CALL THE ON A
TWENTY SEVENTY. MY IS TO PASS
TO. CALL FIVE CALL HI FLORA
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER I
REYES SEYARTO. ZERO DO I WARD
WORD I'D LEAVE THE BILL'S RECORD
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MR GARCIA. WE GET TO JUMP AHEAD
YOUR BILL BECAUSE YOU ARE HERE.
AB TWENTY NINE OH THREE WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY THANK THANK YOU
SHARON COLLEAGUES. A BETWEEN ALL
THREE WOULD ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK FOR TO PURCHASE A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO GET THE
LITHIUM ECONOMY OF THE STATE OFF
THE GROUND- THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT EMPHASIS IN. THE
REGION THAT I REPRESENTS ALL SEE
JOKER MORE RESOURCE AREA WHICH
IS HOME TO THE LARGEST LITHIUM
DEPOSIT IN THE UNITED STATES-
JUST TODAY SECRETARY OF ENERGY.
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE OUT THERE
DISCUSSING THESE OPPORTUNITIES
THE ALIGNMENT THAT TAKES PLACE
OR EXISTS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S BOSAN OBJECTIVES
AND I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU ALL
THE THAT THEY ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA'S. ELECTRIFICATION
TRANSPORTATION GOES WELL I'LL
STOP THERE WE HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT WILL TESTIFY THAT THE JOHN
WHITE THE POWER CAMPAIGN. PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS JOHN
WHITE WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN IN BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY
ENERGY OF. WE THINK THAT THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT THOUGH BECAUSE
THE KEY TO ESTABLISHING
COMMUNITY BENEFITS FOR THE
SALTON SEA AREA IS WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
THE WORKERS NEEDED FOR THIS NEW
INDUSTRY WILL BE ABLE TO COME
FROM THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. IN
THIS APPRENTICESHIP FRAMEWORK
THAT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED LOOKS
LIKE A WAY TO TRANSITION PEOPLE
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
AND GIVE THEM THE SKILLS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO BE COMPETITIVE AND
TO PROVIDE THE WORKFORCE NEEDED
SO WE WOULD ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY
NINE OH THREE.
HELLO ALEX GIBBS HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF IMPERIAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE'S A SHARE
SUPPORT IN CONCEPT FOR THIS BILL
THAT'S THE GENERALLY ALIGNS WITH
THE LITHIUM VALIUM INVESTMENT
PLAN. HOWEVER THE BOARD HAS NOT
HAD A CHANCE YET TO TAKE A
FORMAL POSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE. BUT
A MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE OH
THREE. YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE OH THREE IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO. THAT ISN'T SUPPORTS ONE
VAN DER ROHE. WE DO HAVE
SOMEBODY CARING UP IT'LL BE JUST
A MOMENT.
AGAIN THAT IS. ONE NINE ZERO.
JUST ONE SECOND HERE THEY'RE
GETTING OUR LINE NUMBER AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
ONE HE THOUGHT HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ERIC FOR AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISABEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN Q. MISTER CAREFULLY
THOUGHT OUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK FOR OPPOSITION ANYONE. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE OH
THREE. WE HAVE NO REGISTERED
OFFICER XIN NOBODY IN THE ROOM
BUT A MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO A BETWEEN
A THREE. HAVE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE OR
THREE IT'S ONE NINE ZERO. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP MR
CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTIONS. OKAY A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE SECOND. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WHAT IS
THE ADDRESS HERE PLEASE REMAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND- WE
SHOULD BE TEAMS ANALYSIS AND AS
REBEL THANK YOU SO MUCH ABOUT A
SECRETARY IN HAVE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON. AB TWENTY NINE OH
THREE. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATE. EIGHTY KALRA AYE
KALRA HI FLORA JONES SAWYER-
JONES SAWYER AYE REYES SIERRA.
ZERO AYE WARD. WARD I BELIEVE
THAT DOUBLES OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH UP NEXT WE'LL HAVE A GO
BACK ABOUT ORDERED ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE IS ON
THE ROAD REGUS. T. MOBILE THANK
YOU. IS THERE A SECOND. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS FOR
LEVERAGE PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINE THIS BILL
WOULD ADDRESS UNDER REPORTING OF
VIOLENCE IN THE WORKPLACE BY
REQUIRING CAL SHOULD DEVELOP
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS REGARDING
THE REGULATIONOF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. PRIVATE SECTOR EMTS
AND PARAMEDICS WORKING A FIELD
WITH OCCUPATIONAL HAZARDS AND
CHALLENGES THAT PLACE THEM AT
RISK OF MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
TRAUMA. BEING IN A NUMBER OF
WORKERS OFTEN PHYSICALLY
EMOTIONALLY AND MENTALLY
DEMANDING- WITHOUT A TWENTY
NINETEEN NATIONAL SERVER
REPORTED TIGHTER VIOLENCE
AGAINST MS PRACTITIONERS REBUILT
ALBUMS WORKERS ARE TWENTY TWO
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO EXPERTS
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE THAN ALL
OTHER OCCUPATIONS ADDITIONALLY
THE VAST MAJORITY INVOLVING
PATIENT FOLKS GO UNREPORTED
BECAUSE I'M WORKERS OFTEN
CENTERED PART OF THE JOB. IT IS
A PERFECT PROVIDED ESSENTIAL
FIRST AND DESERVE TO GO TO WORK
WITHOUT FEAR BEING ASSAULTED AND
ARMED AB TWENTY OR TWENTY I
RECOGNIZE THE POINT OF WORK OF
EMS WORKERS AND DIRECTS OSHA TO
TAKE THE STEPS TO PROTECT THEM
FROM THE WORKPLACE VIOLENCE THEY
OFTEN FACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I KNOW PRIMARY
WITNESSES. OKAY SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONES MADAM
MODERATOR BUT ACTUALLY IN THE
AUDIENCE SORRY IN THE AUDIENCE
PLEASE ANYONE IS SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE.
INVESTORS ARE MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
. BURKE AT TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
NINE IT IS ONE NINE ZERO. THAT
IS IN SUPPORT LONDON ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP HERE TO BE
JUST A MOMENT. WE WILL GO TO
FIND NUMBER. TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF EMTS AND PARAMEDICS AT THE
ARE YOU LOCAL FIVE THOUSAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE
INFO YOU MISTER. THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY SO TWENTY
NINE. BOB WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES BETTER MONITORING WHEN
OPPOSITION LEADERS WITH ME NINE
. FOR AN OPPOSITION IT IS MY
MENTOR- OPPOSITION OF ONE VENN
VERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
IN Q. MISTER CARE PLEASE
CONTINUE I THANK YOU OF ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. JUDGE
CLOSER. OR FOR CRASH RIVAL ALL
RIGHT METACENTRIC TAKE ROLL CALL
. ON A BETWEEN SEVENTY NINE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA FIVE KALRA
I'D FLORA JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE REYES ZERO ZERO AYE
WARD WARD I LEAVE. THOSE ON THIS
TOPIC. THIRTY WELL. ALL RIGHTS.
FOR JERRY JONES SAWYER OF TO
HELP ME OUT HERE ON ITEM
EIGHTEEN IT'S- AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
ONE. WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN
ARGUMENT A- ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE KALRA. YOU MAY
BE IN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU SO MUCH JERRY JONES
SAWYER. I'M NOT SURE MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE THE WORKPLACE
TECHNOLOGY ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS
BOTH CRITICAL TO OUR FUTURE OF
WORK AND ENSURING WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED FROM UNDUE
DISCRIMINATION. AND SURVEILLANCE
. AS A FORMER COMMISSIONER ON
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE OF WORK
COMMISSION I HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH WITH BOTH INDUSTRY AND
WORKER ADVOCATES ABOUT THE
INCREASING USE OF DATA DRIVEN
TECHNOLOGY IN THE WORKPLACE. OUR
FINAL REPORT RECOMMENDED THAT
POLICYMAKERS ADOPT REGULATIONS
TO PROTECT WORKERS FROM THE
HARMS OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES. MY
DISTRICT IS LOOKING VALUE PACKS
HOUSING WE CALL OURSELVES THE
CAPITAL A SILICON VALLEY UNITS
WHERE COMPANIES ARE CONSTANTLY
RELEASING NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
DEPLOY IN THE WORKPLACE.
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE SOFTWARE TO
SELECT JOB APPLICANTS
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS TO MONITOR
THE PACE OF WORK AND APPS TO
TRACK WORKERS LOCATIONS OR
MOVEMENTS SOMETIMES WHETHER IT
ON DUTY AND I DON'T WORKING. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE WHAT IS TO
MUCH NEEDED YET REASONABLE%
LIMITATIONS ON HOW EMPLOYERS USE
DATA DRIVEN TECHNOLOGY AT WORK.
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT
BAN TECHNOLOGY EXCEPT FOR
PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS DATA
TOOLS LIKE FACIAL RECOGNITION.
THE KEY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
POLICIES THAT RESTRICT THE
SHARING OF CONSUMER INFORMATION
TO THIRD PARTIES AND THIS BILL
IS THAT AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
POWER IMBALANCE BETWEEN A WORKER
AND AN EMPLOYER. THAT YOU HAVE
AN APP THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS YOU USE YOUR
DATA YOU KNOW THE IS THE UP. BUT
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BURGER
THEIR EMPLOYER IS A VERY VERY
DIFFERENT. WORKERS ENTERED PLAY
EMPLOYER RELATIONSHIP WITH
LITTLE BARGAINING POWER. THEIR
EMPLOYERS ARE COLLECTING MINING
AND IN SOME CASES SHARING
WORKERS DATA WITHOUT WORKERS
HAVING ANY IDEA IT'S HAPPENING.
TO WHAT EXTENT IT'S HAPPENING OR
HOW THE EMPLOYER MAY BE USING IT
TO MAKE EMPLOYMENT RELATED
DECISIONS SUCH AS PROMOTION.
FIRING OR IMPOSING DISCIPLINE.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE DOES THREE
CRITICAL THINGS TO CREATE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE USE OF WORKPLACE
TECHNOLOGY. FIRST IT ENSURES
THAT WORKERS ARE NOTIFIED PRIOR
TO DATA COLLECTION USE OF
ELECTRONIC MONITORING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF ALGORITHMS. SECOND
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
TECHNOLOGY BE USED FOR A VALID
BUSINESS PRACTICE AND BE JOB
RELATED. THIRD IT REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO CONDUCT IMPACT
ASSESSMENTS WITH WORKER INPUT ON
ALGORITHMS AND DATA COLLECTION
TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL HARMS AND
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACTS. THE TIME
IS NOW TO ADDRESS THE INCREASING
USE OF UNREGULATED DATA DRIVEN
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE WORKPLACE
AND GIVE WORKERS AND THE STATE
THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO MITIGATE
ANY INSIDIOUS IMPACTS CAUSED BY
THEM. WITH ME PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IS SUPPORT OUR MID STEIGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND DOUG BLOCK WITH TEAMSTERS
JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN. AND ON THE
PHONE PROTECTING THOSE QUESTIONS
IS ANNETTA BERNARD SPEAKING IN
HER CAPACITY AS ONE OF THE
AUTHORS THE UC BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER REPORT. DATA AND
ALGORITHMS AT WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU HAVE A FIVE MINUTES
TWO MINUTES APIECE WHATEVER WAY
YOU WANT TO DIVIDE IT UP. RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL. ALONG WITH THE SEIU
STATE COUNCIL ON THE U. OF C. W.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL. ARE ALSO
A LOT OF OTHER LABOR GROUPS AND
WORK PROTECTION ORGANIZATIONS
AND PRIVACY ORGANIZATIONS. WE
REALLY BELIEVE THE SIZE AND
BREADTH OF THAT COALITION
REFLECTS THE- REACH AND SEVERITY
OF THE PROBLEM. THAT GOES FAR
DEEPER AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED
THAN JUST AN INVASION OF WORKERS
PRIVACY. AT ITS WORST THIS
TECHNOLOGY REALLY DOES
CONSTITUTE AN ATTACK ON
VIRTUALLY ALL OF YOUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS AS A WORKER
AND- WORSE YET IT'S OFTEN HIDDEN
ONE. EXAMPLE OF AN APP WITH
GEOLOCATION DATA WAS MENTIONED
THAT'S A REALLY CRITICAL ONE FOR
US BECAUSE THAT CAN BE USED TO
TRACK A WORKER ON AND OFF THE
JOB. WITH THE OBVIOUS A VERY
GRAVE RISK TO YOUR RIGHT TO
ORGANIZE. THERE IS ALSO THE
ISSUE OF SAY ON EMPLOYER GIVING
YOU A COMPANY PROVIDED LAPTOP
THAT CAN CONDUCT VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE OF YOU WHEN YOU'RE
IN YOUR HOME. VIDEOTAPING
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING
BEHIND YOU AND USING THAT DATA
THAT'LL- THIS COLLECTED. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT
DECISIONS. ELDORET NOW KNOWLEDGE
HE HAS REALLY PER TO THE POINT
WHERE IT CAN BE USED TO DENY
WORKERS AN INTERVIEW TO ADJUST
YOUR SCHEDULE DR PAY DISCIPLINE
AND FIRE YOU. AND NO ONE REALLY
EVEN KNOWS HOW IT WORKS IT'S
JUST OUT THERE AND SO WITH ALL
OF THE IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS IS THE FACT THAT THE
WORKERS NOT EVEN AWARE THAT IT'S
HAPPENING. AND SO THEY DON'T.
HAPPENING UNTIL IT'S TOO LATE
THEY'RE VERY LITTLE RIGHTS WITH
RESPECT TO IT AND SO AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE IS REALLY A
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF THESE. IT HAS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED GIVES A WORKER
NOTICED THAT IT'S BEING USED.
GIVES A WORKER THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS AND CORRECT THE DATA
WHERE WHERE THAT'S APPROPRIATE
AND THEN ALSO STOP SOME OF THE
WORST ABUSES. LIKE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE OF ITS WELL
DOCUMENTED RACIALLY DISPARATE
IMPACT AND ALSO OBVIOUSLY
TRACKING WORKERS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT AT WORK. BUT REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE OF THE FACT
THAT THE BILL REALLY DOESN'T BAN
VERY MUCH. THAT IT ESSENTIALLY
SAYS THE EMPLOYER CAN USE ALL OF
THIS BUDGET WHEREVER IT MAKES
SENSE WHEREVER IT'S RELATED TO
THE TASK AT HAND. AND IN DOING
SO WE THINK IT REALLY DOES
FINALLY ALIGN. OUR STATUS IN
CALIFORNIA AS A CENTER FOR
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION BUT
ALSO PLACE THAT REALLY RESPECTS
WORKERS RIGHTS. AND REALLY
BRINGS THEM TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS BOTH. IN A- SPECIAL
TO EVERYONE INVOLVED SO WE URGE
OUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I HAVE
THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING THE
TEAMSTERS UNION TODAY JUST AS I
DID WHEN I SERVED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION WITH MISTER KALRA.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT UNITED
PARCEL SERVICE THE LARGEST
UNIONIZED EMPLOYER IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND TEAMSTERS.
NOW I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
YOUR SMART PHONES IN YOUR CAR'S
. BETWEEN A HAND HELD COMPUTER
SENSORS ON THE TRUCKS AND A
NAVIGATION SYSTEM HERE'S THE
DATA THE UPS COLLECTS ON US
EVERY DAY. OUR VEHICLE SPEED
LOCATION HOW HARD WE HIT THE
BRAKES. IDOLING TIME FUEL
CONSUMPTION WHETHER WE HAVE OUR
SEAT BELTS ON THE HOURS WE WORK
AND HOW LONG IT TAKES TO MAKE
DELIVERIES. THE SYSTEM EVEN TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T MAKE ANY LEFT
TURNS ALONG THE WAY BECAUSE THAT
TAKES MORE TIME AND USES MORE
GAS. ROCKING ALL OF THIS IS
CALLED TELEMATICS AND USED RIGHT
IT ACTUALLY MAKES OUR JOBS
EASIER AND MORE EFFICIENT. BUT
THERE'S A DARK SIDE TO.
TELEMATICS WORKS VERY WELL FOR
U. P. S. IT HAD ITS MOST
PROFITABLE YEAR EVER AND THANKS
TO US THEY SHARE THOSE PROFITS
WITH OUR MEMBERS. THE UNION
CONTRACT EVEN SAYS NO DRIVER CAN
GET FIRED BECAUSE OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY THE
HUMAN SUPERVISOR HAS TO OBSERVE
YOUR BEHAVIOR NOT THE ALGORITHM.
THIS ISN'T TRUE FOR AMAZON
DRIVERS WHO GET FIRED WITH NO
RECOURSE OR GRIEVANCE PROCEDURE.
THEY DO THE SAME WORK THAT WE DO
AND ALL WORKERS SHOULD HAVE
EQUAL RIGHTS NOT JUST UNION
WORKERS. IN ERROR WITH AN
ALGORITHM MAY NOT BE A BIG DEAL
FOR A CORPORATION BUT FOR A
WORKER CAN BE CATASTROPHIC IT
COULD MEAN LOSING YOUR JOB
GETTING INJURED OR EVEN DEATH.
OUR GOVERNMENT RULES AND
REGULATIONS NEED TO CATCH THE
TECHNOLOGY AND AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
ONE IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
GIVING WORKERS THE PROTECTIONS
THEY NEED. IF YOU PS CAN. AND
USE ALL THIS OLOGY SO CAN ANY
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER I'LL BE
HAPPY HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW
GO TO THE ROOM UNDER ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT. OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE
KALRA YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AS A GROW WITH
UFCW WESTERN STATES COUNSEL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SK OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MATT BROAD
FOR THE TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE
MACHINISTS UTILITY WORKERS I AN
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SERAPH LOCKS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. CAN WHEN CALIFORNIANS
WOMAN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BECAUSE THE
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
BOARD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU- WILL NOW GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OPPOSITION- TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION COULD YOU
GIVE- I'M SORRY. FORGOT ABOUT
THE PHONES WE GO TO THE PHONES-
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR COULD YOU
OPEN UP THE PHONES FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE. YEAH AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO FOR THE
PORT. AND WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN
THE U. LOCAL TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALLISTER YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIMO
TIMELINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY BURKE WITH THE
AMERICAN POSITION FOR ST JOHN
UNITS ONE POSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU. IN
MAXIMO CAROLINE AND NINETY
PLEASE SO I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE DEFENDER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT. NEXT SOME OF THE LINE
NINETY TWO PEOPLE I HAD. SECOND
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. IN MAXIMO TO LINE EIGHT
PM BEFORE I HAD. PREPOSITIONS-
IT. OKAY MAXIMO TIMELINE AB
PLEASE BY HAD. WHAT THE CRAP
PARKER RESEARCH CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY SIXTEEN FIFTY
ONE. ENACT THE MULTI LINE NINETY
ONE PUPIL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HANNAH HOLLOWAY AFFECT EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE CALLING IN SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME THERE IS NO
OTHER CALLERS IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM OPPOSITION
COULD YOU GIVE US A LITTLE ROOMS
BUT- WE CAN HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY. HI YOU
HAVE JUST THE SAME. YOU CAN DO
ALL THE FIVE MINUTES APIECE JUST
YOU BUDGET. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPOSITION. I MEAN BEFORE
ADDRESSING THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL I DO JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT ABOUT PROCESS AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT GOTTEN AMENDS
ARE VERY COMMON LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS ABSOLUTELY BUT- OUR
CONCERN HERE IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO THE SPONSORS ABOUT
THE ISSUE PRIVACY EMPLOYER
RIGHTS FOR MONTHS WE REACHED OUT
IN THE FALL- BECAUSE OF ISSUES
RELATED TO PROVISIONS OF THE
CPRE THAT ARE GOING TO EXPIRE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WHEN THEY
TOLD US THAT THEY WERE EXPLORING
A BILL DEALING WITH POTENTIALLY
TRACKING EMPLOYEREMPLOYEES
OUTSIDE OF WORKING HOURS IN EDS
WE COMMITTED YOU KNOW TO TRYING
TO WORK WITH THEM ON THAT THEY
TOLD US REPEATEDLY THAT WE WOULD
SEE LANGUAGE- WITHIN WEEKS- IT.
IN FROM ONE WEEK TO TWO WEEKS-
AND SO WE WERE QUITE FRANKLY
SHOCKED ON MONDAY WHEN I WENT TO
SEE IF THERE WAS AN ANALYSIS
POSTED AND I FOUND A THIRTY
THREE PAGE BILL- THAT WE HAD
NEVER BEEN INFORMED OF AND WE
HAD NEVER BEEN SET IN ADVANCE-
AND SO AGAIN IT WAS JUST REALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR US TO HAVE TO
WALK IN. TRYING TO SCRAMBLE TO
GET FEEDBACK ON THIS- WITHIN
LESS THAN FORTY EIGHT HOURS I'M
IN ALSO THE DAY BEFORE THE OTHER
COMMITTEE THAT IS NOW WE'RE FOR
THIS BILL IS NOW BEEN REFERRED
TO WAS ACTUALLY ABOUT TO HAVE
ITS LAST HEARING IS NOW GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE A SPECIAL HEARING
NEXT WEEK- SO NEEDLESS TO SAY WE
ARE. FOR QUITE DISAPPOINTED I
THINK WITH THE PROCESS OF HOW-
THIS BILL WENT TO PRINCE- AND WE
REALLY DO NOT CONDONE THAT
BEHAVIOR. I'M SO JUST TURNING
BRIEFLY TO SUBSTANCE- ARE
MEMBERS OF COURSE GIVEN TO BE
GOTTEN AMANDA THIRTY THREE PAGES
ON MONDAY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FULLY DIGEST THE BILL. BUT ON
OUR END YOU ARE SORRY REVIEW THE
BILL WE DO INTEND TO GET A JOB
KILLER- QUITE FRANKLY THE BILL.
WHILE THERE. A LOT IN HIS YOU
KNOW OF WHAT SPONSORS. SAID WE
ARE AB. COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THIS BILL GOES FAR BEYOND
THAT'S- SO FOR EXAMPLE IS
BASICALLY AN EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE
TO REVIEW EVERY SINGLE EMPLOYEE
OR DOCUMENT THAT AN EMPLOYEE
EVER PRODUCES TO SEE IF THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO STORE IT. I MEAN YOU
CAN'T TAKE ANY SORT OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION ON SOMETHING
THAT CAN'T BE CORROBORATED SO IF
LIKE- ONE OF THE SYSTEMS THAT
WAS MENTIONED RIGHT SHOWS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN GOING LIKE NINETY
MILES PER HOUR SOMETHING IN A
SCHOOL ZONE. THAT'S NOT
COOPERATED IF THERE'S NOT
SOMEONE ELSE THERE WITH YOU. AN
EMPLOYER CAN MAKE NO
DISCIPLINARY ACT. THAT I ALSO
WILL REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIAL HR INVESTIGATION
PRIVILEGED DOCUMENTS AND- OSHA
IN D. I. R. WOULD HAVE TO.
ACTIVELY APPROVED EVERY SINGLE
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY THAT AN
EMPLOYEE USES GIVEN THE BREADTH
OF THE DEFINITION. SO AGAIN
WHILE WE APPRECIATE WHAT. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE AUTHORS TRYING TO
DO HERE WE REALLY JUST. HAVE A
LOT OF ISSUES WITH THIS BILL WE
DON'T THINK IT'S WORKABLE AT ALL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM. I'M
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOUR PENALTIES
I'M GOING UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FACTORED BILL APPLIES
BUSINESS IN. ALL SIZES NOT JUST
BIG BUSINESSES SMALL AS WELL- SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY
URGE A NO VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- BUT NOW GO TO THE
ROOM. HIS WITHIN THE- HEARING.
THE ARE OPPOSED TO BILL NAME IN
ORGANISE. PLEASE I DON'T ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET POST THANK YOU. RESEARCHER CHRIS MAKAYLA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY ALLIANCE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON THE ONLY
PETRONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
AS WELL AS THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON WITTY CIGAR SEE WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS GROCERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU- FOR NOW GO TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES ANY WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION. BY EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE. YES AND MAYBE EVEN
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO UPHOLD
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN ONE BEEN ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO A POLLS AND WE DO HAVE ABOUT
THREE IN THE QUEUE. GLOBAL TEL
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHARRON MEMBERS COURTNEY
GENTS AND ON BEHALF OF THE JACK
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOUNG.
MAXIMO TIELINE EIGHT TEAM LEAVE-
I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RYAN ELAINE-
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR I HAVE ABOUT TWO MORE
AND YOU WILL GO TO LINE NINETY
FIVE MAX ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AS A TEEN CAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION HERE
SPECTRAL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MELANIE CUEVAS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
AUTHORED BY POPULATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU IT MEANS YOU HAVE A
ONE MARIN MAKE YOU ALMOST THE
LINE NINETY FOUR. PEOPLE HAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HAPPENING HELP AND LET'S BE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL NOW
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD THANK YOU I WANT TO-
THINK THAT CHAIR ARE CALLING FOR
WORKING ON THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S TIME TO SEND YOU KNOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT- LEADER OUR THAT
YOU KNOW. YOU WANT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION RIGHT THE WORLD IS
CHANGING FAST THERE IS A LOT OF
IMPORTANT- IMPROVEMENTS TO BE
DONE IN THIS SPACE- IF WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT AT A MINIMUM
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES- TO SO THEY UNDERSTAND
HOW INFORMATION MIGHT BE-
MONITOR TRACKED- YOU KNOW BOTH
IN AND OUT OF THE WORKPLACE.
THERE IS JUST A LOT BECAUSE OF
ALL THE OP- SOCKS SOMETIMES WHEN
I HEAR ABOUT HOW ANALYTICS COULD
BE- YOU KNOW TRACKING ME AS A
CONSUMER- AND CERTAINLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE- I HAVE
SOME SENSE OF DIGNITY AND A
SENSE OF- TO THE RIGHT AGREE
PRIVACY- IN GOING ABOUT ON THE
WORK THAT THEY DO AND THEY THEY
PROBABLY DO. I'M SO I DO WANT TO
SEE THIS ABSOLUTELY MOVE FORWARD
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT TO- REALLY
DIGEST HERE WORK THROUGH MANY
COMMITTEES HOPEFULLY LIE AHEAD
THAT WILL REALLY GET INTO SO
MANY OF THESE SPECIFIC ISSUES-
BUT I DO WONDER YOU KNOW IN THIS
COMMITTEE OFTEN HOW WE TALK
ABOUT EMPLOYEE MISS
CLASSIFICATION- AND HOW- WHETHER
OR NOT WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE-
IN IN IN THAT SORT OF EVOLUTION
AS WELL- WITH REGARD TO THE-
BILL. HOW IT MIGHT APPLY TO
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR OTHER
WAYS THAT NOT PLEASE NOT
LABELED- AND WHAT IS OUR
ABILITIES TO THEM TO OTHER-
WORKERS- IN IN IN. ANY INDUSTRY.
SURE THAT THEY ARE EQUALLY BEING
AFFORDED PROTECTIONS AND THEIR
PRIVACY AND. AND TRACKING YOUR
INFORMATION. IT I COULD JUST
CHECK OUT. MR BLOCK HAS IN
COMMON ON THAT. SURE YES YOU
WITH A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO AMAZON IS
AN EXAMPLE. STARTING AGAIN WITH
UPS WHERE SOMEBODY WITH A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CAN MAKE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
DRIVING FOR UPS. FULLY PAID
FAMILY HEALTH INSURANCE AND A
PENSION. DELIVERING PRIMARILY
AMAZON PACKAGES WHERE UPS DRIVER
MAKES ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR WITH NO PENSION-
OR I'M AN AMAZON DRIVER I'M
SORRY SO. ON THE ISSUE OF MIS
CLASSIFICATION AND
SUBCONTRACTING THIS IS THIS IS
THE HEART OF THE PROBLEM THERE
THESE UPS TRUCKS OR AT AMAZON
TRUCKS WEARING AMAZON UNIFORMS.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY WORK FOR
AMAZON THEY WORK FOR
SUBCONTRACTORS OF THE COMPANY-
ALTHOUGH IT'S AMAZON'S
TELEMATICS SYSTEMS THAT SURVEIL
THE WORKERS AND CAUSE THEM TO BE
DISCIPLINED. THE SAME IS TRUE
FOR THE AMAZON FLEX DRIVERS WHO
ARE PEOPLE DELIVERING PACKAGES
IN THEIR OWN CARS THEY ARE
MISCLASSIFIED INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS MISCLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES REALLY. AND THEY ARE
LIKE UBER FOR PACKAGE DELIVERY
IN THE TELEMATICS IN THAT CASE
ACTUALLY SET THEIR WAGES. SO
THESE ARE THE STORIES OF THE
TELEMATICS SO THE PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE IT'S DYNAMIC PRICING
IT'S BASED THIS IS HOW UBER
WORKS TO BASED ON SUPPLY AND
DEMAND AT THAT EXACT MOMENT IN
TIME THAT SETS YOUR COMPENSATION
. AND SO THAT IS ON CHECK TO THE
FUTURE OF WORK FOR ALL OF US THE
IN MY OPINION FROM OUR TIME ON
THE FUTURE WORK COMMISSION THE
ROBOT APOCALYPSE IS NOT THE
ROBOTS COMING TO TAKE OUR JOBS
IT'S THE ROBOTS COMING TO
SUPERVISE US. AND THAT'S WHY
THIS LEGISLATION IS IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU FOR THE PIZZA WITH THE
BILL. THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE.
I THOUGHT I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR BRING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND OFFER ALL THE
SPONSORS WORK ON THIS AND HAVE
CONFIDENCE OF THE MANY COMMITTEE
HEARINGS FOR YOU IRON OUT THE
DETAILS OF THESE THINGS. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA BEING
A LARGE ECONOMIES WE ARE IN THE
COUNTRY TO FOLLOW OUR EUROPEAN
PEERS AND TO PROTECT DATA JUST
AS WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE COLLECTION APPLICATION OF
DATA WHEN IT COMES TO BIG
GOVERNMENTS OR ITS STATE
SPONSORED ENTITIES WE ALSO MUST
BE ON THE GUARD ABOUT BIG
CORPORATIONS AS WELL WHICH RUN
UNFETTERED. AND DUG YOUR POINT
ABOUT ROBOTS BECOMING A
SUPERVISOR SAID MOSTLY BECOMING
THAT WORKFORCE THAT IS ALSO TRUE
I MEAN ANY PERSON THAT THEY
COULD SOCIAL MEDIA TODAY ALREADY
HAS A MANAGER AS A PERSON THAT
PERSONAL CURATOR OF SOCIAL MEDIA
BE AN ALGORITHM. AND THAT IS
BECAUSE BE THAT APPLICATION
THROUGHOUT THE SENSE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT NOT ONLY REINFORCE THE
CONSENT OF A WORKER RIGHT THAT
KNOWING WHAT IS BEING SHARED HOW
TO APPLY. THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
AND INNATELY WITH BIG DATA L.
ANOTHER OUT DATA ANALYSTS IN
GENERAL YOU KNOW THE SET OF THE
CHAIR AND I'LL COME FROM THE
CAPITAL OF SILICON VALLEY AND WE
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE IN
THAT. THERE'S A LOT OF UNTAPPED-
POTENTIAL AN APPLICATION THAT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW OF BUT IT'S VERY
VERY MICHAEL AND HE CAN EXTRACT
SO MUCH FROM CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS THAT'S
WHAT THE POINT OF BUILDING THESE
GUARDRAILS SENSE ARE VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT. AND. YEAH SECOND
ALREADY. OKAY ANYONE ELSE BUT
AND NOT WHAT THANK YOU THE THIS
THIS ISSUE- I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN WHEN HE WILL RETIRE
ALGORITHMS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO- HIRING PEOPLE OF COLOR
THEY MAKING SURE YOU DON'T-
USING ALGORITHMS TO TAKE OUT THE
RACIAL PREJUDICE IN THE HIRING
PROCESS THAT I RAN INTO A LOT OF
PROBLEMS. WITH WITH THAT AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I LEARNED AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
AT WE ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THIS
WHERE SHE GO THROUGH EACH OF THE
PARAMETERS THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE YOU COULD PROGRAM
THIS TO YOU COULD ACTUALLY-
SEGREGATE OUT PEOPLE YOU DON'T
WANT. IF IT'S PROGRAM IN
INAPPROPRIATELY. AND WHICH I
NEVER THOUGHT ANYONE WOULD DO
THAT BUT I'D SAY NEED TO LEARN.
THAT THIS WORLD IS A- AS BAD AS
THEY THINK IT IS ALL THE TIME.
AND THEN WHEN IT CAME TO A
FACIAL RECOGNITION WHICH I'M UP.
I WAS A BIG PROPONENT OF. UNTIL
ONE DAY THEY DID THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION AND SHOWED EVERYONE
THAT HAD A FELONY. CONVICTION ON
THE LAWN AND ONE OF THOSE PLACES
WITH MINE. AND I DON'T HAVE A
FELONY CONVICTION. AND THEY HAD
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SO
AGAIN WHAT EVER PROGRAMMING THAT
WAS DONE BY HUMANS- RESULTED IN-
IN ACCURATE INFORMATION THAT
COULD ADVERSELY IMPACT. IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS TO COULD
YOU COULD BE VERY DEVASTATING TO
AN EMPLOYEE. AND SO WE NEED TO I
STILL BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO USED
THIS TECHNOLOGY AND I BELIEVE
BUSINESSES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
USE IT. BUT WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
SOME KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY OF
STABILITY AND ABILITY TO ENSURE
ACCURACY. IS THE PER MONTH BEING
THAT WE DO WHEN WE USE ANY OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE I
THE BILL. AND SO- DEFINITELY
GOING TO MOVE THIS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE- I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A REALLY ROBUST
CONVERSATION. WITHOUT THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND THE
CHAMBER AND YOU NEED TO KIND OF
SAY WHAT ARE WE WHAT ARE WE
TRYING TO DO. MMHM HOW ARE WE
TRYING TO MAKE IT BETTER NOT
ONLY FOR EMPLOYEES BUT DEPLOYER
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT. MAKING
SURE THE DEUCE INTEGRITY. IN
WHAT EVER WE DECIDE WE'RE GOING
TO DO AND I'M SO GLAD WE'RE-
WORK WERE NOW BEGINNING THIS
CONVERSATION I MEAN I WAS ONLY
HAD A LITTLE PIECE OF IT. BUT I
TO REALIZE HOW ROBUST.
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE RIGHT NOW IN
THE EMPLOYMENT SECTOR AND I'M
GLAD WE'RE BEGINNING THIS
DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW
IT'S HARD. BUT LIKE LIKE LOVE
THE CHAMBER SAID IS WHAT THIRTY
THREE PAGES. OF THINGS WE NEED
TO LOOK AT. IT SO- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE YOU MAY CLOSE WELL
THANK YOU MR CHAIRPERSON PAUL
FOR YOU BEING WILL TAKE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND I
RECALL THOSE CONVERSATIONS
DISTINCTLY LOOK IT WAS AS HONEST
AND WELL INTENTIONED QUESTIONS
YOU THIS BY WOULD BE NECESSARY
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN
YOU'RE USING THESE KINDS OF
ANALYTICS FOR MAKING SUCH
CRITICAL DECISIONS IN ONE'S-
EMPLOYMENT OF THE WORKERS DO A
PRICE AND IT IS DOABLE AS WE
HEARD FROM MR BLOCK. OF UPS DOES
IT AND THEY DO IT IN WITH LABOR
CONTRACTS EVERYONE AGREES THAT
THERE'S CERTAIN DATA THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR GREATER
EFFICIENCY- THAT HELPS EVERYONE
INVOLVED HELPS THEM BECOME
PROFITABLE MORE PROFITABLE AND
SO I AM MORE THAN WILLING TO
HAVE A WELL INTENTIONED AND
REASONED AND A CONVERSATION WITH
THE CHAMBER OR ANYONE ELSE IF
THEIR GOAL IS TO HAVE AN
ENDPOINT. THAT ACTUALLY HELPS US
. PUT SOME PRIDE. ON TECHNOLOGY
THE CITY THAT THE GOAL IS JUST
TO NOT DO ANYTHING THAT'S
DIFFERENT BECAUSE YOU KNOW I
DON'T WATCH THE TV SHOW
SEVERANCE LATELY. I THINK WHEN
MOST OF US WATCH IT. WE SEE SOME
DYSTOPIAN WORKPLACE HELP PLACE
TO THE FUTURE HELLSCAPE OF THE
FUTURE. SOMETIMES A PIECE OF THE
CHAMBER OF THAT THAT'S OUR TEN
YEAR PLAN. AND WE CAN'T HELP
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME SENSE.
THAT WORKERS HAVE RIGHTS THEY
HAVE SELF DETERMINATION IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THERE AREN'T RULES WE ALL
ABIDE BY RULES IN OUR WORKPLACE.
AND MANY TIMES THOSE RULES CAN
CREATE GREATER EFFICIENCY. BUT
THIS IS THE MOMENT THAT WE NEED
TO REALLY. DIVE DEEP INTO THIS
TO DIG DEEP. AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HAVING MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS NOT DELAYS ARE NOT
JUST WAYS OF CALLING EVERYTHING
A JOB OR THE YOU DON'T LIKE. BUT
ACTUALLY GETTING TO THE TABLE IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO. MY
TABLE IS ALWAYS OPEN TO THEM.
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY US FROM
LABOR. WITH THAT WE HAVE A
PROMOTION IN THE SECOND MATCH
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL. I
BELIEVE THE CHAIR IS AN AYE VOTE
I COULD BE WRONG BUT I BELIEVE
THE- MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION.
KALRA HI KALRA HI FLORA FLORA NO
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I
REYES. REYES SIZE ZERO ZERO TO
KNOW WARD. WORD I'D LEAVE HI LEE
I BELIEVE THAT BILL IS AT. ON TO
PRIVACY CORRECT.
A PASSED THE GAVEL AUTHORITY
BACK TO THE CHAIR MISTER KALRA.
IT'S LIKE HOLDING ON.
ALL RIGHT SO UP NEXT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO WITH
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN.
EVERY YEAR READY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN A
BILL THAT WOULD INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY OF DATA AT THE PORT
DRAYAGE IN THE PARTRIDGE-
INDUSTRY AMID COVERT NINETEEN WE
HAVE SEEN SUPPLY CHAIN DELAYS
THAT HIGHLIGHT THE STRUGGLE TO
MAINTAIN. EFFICIENT GOODS
MOVEMENT OUR NATION'S PORTS AND
WHILE COVE IT WAS LARGELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR SHUTDOWNS AROUND
THE WORLD WIDESPREAD MIS
CLASSIFICATION OF TRUCK DRIVERS
CONTRIBUTED TO A SHORTAGE OF
DRIVERS AND LESS EFFICIENT PORT
OPERATIONS IN RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS. WE COULDN'T GET THE
FURNITURE SWING SPACE ON TIME
BECAUSE IT WAS DELAYED AT THE
PORTS. THE PORTS ARE OUR GATEWAY
TO THE WORLD IN A CRITICAL AND
CRITICAL TO THE FLOW OF GOODS IN
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY. PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN WILL
INVEST BILLIONS ON MODERNIZING
PORTS AND HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
CALLED INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
INTO ACTION TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY AND IDENTIFY
BOTTLENECKS MEMBERS SUPPORT OF
LOS ANGELES HAS RANKED AS THE
NUMBER ONE CONTAINER PORT IN THE
UNITED STATES H. EACH YEAR SINCE
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND. THIS
TRANSLATES TO MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
TRUCKS MOVING FROM THE PORT OF
LA THE PORT. ALL THROUGHOUT L.
A. COUNTY TO THE INLAND EMPIRE
WAREHOUSES AND ALONG THE WAY
THEY PASSED MY DISTRICT. WHICH
INCLUDE THE TO THE FIVE THE TEN
THE SIXTY THE ONE NO ONE THE ONE
TEN THE ONE THIRTY FOUR. AND THE
SEVEN TEN FREEWAYS. LABOUR IN
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR DECADES TO RAISE STANDARDS
AT THE PORTS FROM REDUCING
EMISSIONS TO CRACKING DOWN ON
MISS CLASSIFICATION AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THAT.
WOULD REQUIRE THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO COLLECT AND
CONSOLIDATE SPECIFIED DATA
RELATED TO GOOD MOVEMENT IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SUPPLY CHAIN AND
WOULD REQUIRE THE AGENCY TO MAKE
THIS THAT AT THE STATE OF
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. ON ITS
WEBSITE THIS WORK HAS RESULTED
IN A POWERFUL PARTNERSHIP OF
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES. UNITED TO PUSH FOR
CLEAN AND SAFE PORTS. IN A
VARIETY OF EFFORTS TO HELP IT
THESE CONCERNS HOWEVER THE WORK
IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT'S
CHALLENGING BECAUSE DATA ON THE
PORT DRAYAGE INDUSTRY IS SPREAD
ACROSS MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES.
AND NON MULTIPLE DATABASES THIS
BILL TEMPS TO FILL IN SOME OF
THOSE GAPS AND CREATE A MUCH
NEEDED STANDARD OF DATA
COLLECTION THAT CAN BE ASILY
ACCESSED. WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION OVER THEIR CONCERNS
AND THEY HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
FIND A REASONABLE PATH FORWARD
TODAY HERE TESTIFIED. BLOCKS
WITH THE TEAMS FOR THE- IN ORDER
GONZALEZ WITH THE BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THERE ARE BLOCKS TEACHERS
SUPPORT DIVISION ALSO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR- AND WE ARE PROUD COOKS CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL- ONE OF THE
REASONS IS THAT BEFORE THE
CURRENT SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS. THE
MISS CLASSIFICATION OF PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS CREATED
CONGESTIONS AND DELAYS AND
CREATED A PERFECT STORM THAT
ENABLED THE CURRENT CRISIS
HAPPENS. SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
MISCLASSIFIED IS THAT THEY DON'T
CONTROL THEIR RATES THEY DON'T
CONTROL THEIR HOURS THEY DON'T
CONTROL. ANYTHING THEY BASICALLY
ARE HAVE KIND OF STANDARD
MINIMUM WAGES AND THEY HAVE TO
BEAR THE ENTIRE COST OF BUYING
THEIR TRUCK MAINTAINING THEIR
TRUCK AND FIGURING OUT HOW TO
GET ENOUGH JOBS TO GET BY. WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE NOT PAID BY THE
HOUR SO THEY COULD SIT FOR TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX HOURS
IDOLING WAITING FOR CARGO TO
COME IT. THERE'S ALSO NO REAL
ABILITY TO TRACK AND CONTROL AND
HAVE AN EFFICIENT WORKFORCE WHEN
YOU HAVE THE FLEET YOU CAN
DEPLOY A TRUCK DRIVERS SO YOU
CAN HAVE. TWENTY FOUR HOUR SEVEN
DAY A WEEK OPERATIONS AT THE
PORT. RIGHT NOW WE CAN'T AND SO.
THE NARRATIVE IN THE PRESS AND
EVEN IN THE NEW YORK TIMES TODAY
TALKING ABOUT ALMOND GROWERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THAT WE HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF TRUCK DRIVERS- AT
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS. YOU DON'T
HAVE A SHORTAGE WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF GOOD DIRECT
EMPLOYMENT JOBS AT THE PORT THAT
ENABLE THE EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF
CARGO. THE OTHER THING IS THAT
IN COMPLIANCE WITH- CLEAN
VEHICLES WITH THE TRANSITION TO
CLEAN VEHICLES MUCH LOWER AMONG
THIS CLASSIFIED TRUCK DRIVERS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT.
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T AND SO THAT
HAS AN IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING PORTS AND SO NOW WE
HAVE THIS CLASS. IMPACTING TRUCK
DRIVERS THE COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE PORTS AND OUR BROADER
ECONOMY. AND SO WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IS THAT THE BITE ADMINISTRATION
IS SAYING WE NEED MORE
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN FROM THE OCEAN LINERS TO
THE POOR EXT OUT TO THE
INTERSTATE COMMERCE WELL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T
CONTROL WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
SEAS WE CAN'T CONTROL INTERSTATE
COMMERCE. BUT WE CAN HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AT THE PORTS WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
40% OF THE GOODS NATIONWIDE
HELLO AND SO THIS BILL REALLY IS
SAYING OKAY LET'S LOOK AT OUR
PORTS LET'S COLLECT ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IS OUT THERE.
AND IDENTIFY SOME OF THE GAPS
LET'S LOOK AT WHO IS EIGHT
EMPLOYEE TRUCK DRIVER IN WHO IS
MISCLASSIFIED AND PUT THAT IN
ONE PLACE SO THAT WE CAN START
TO MOVE TOWARDS THAT
TRANSPARENCY. HOPE THAT WE CRACK
DOWN ON ILLEGAL MIS
CLASSIFICATION AT THE PORT. ALSO
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE EFFICIENT
GOODS MOVEMENTS AND CREATE
BETTER JOBS BECAUSE IF IT'S NOT
A SHORTAGE OF TRUCK DRIVERS BUT
IT'S A SHORTAGE OF GOOD JOBS
THAT WE NEED TO START KNOWING.
ARE WE STARTING TO MEET OUR
GOALS ARE WE SEEING THAT WHEN WE
HAVE EMPLOYEE DRIVERS THERE'S
MORE EFFICIENCY- AND GET TO THAT
POINT TO REALLY THIS IS LAYING
THE FOUNDATION SO THAT
POLICYMAKERS RESEARCHERS THE
PORT DIRECTORS. HAVE THIS
INFORMATION IN ONE PLACE TO
START MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT-
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I- DRIVER. THANK YOU
MEMBERS OR THROUGH AND SALAS ON
BEHALF OF THE BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE
A PARTNERSHIP OF STATE LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING TOWARDS THE COMMON GOAL.
OF ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES WHILE MAINTAINING A
GOOD PAYING JOBS AND INEQUITABLE
ECONOMY. I TOOK A REMAINS ONE OF
THE MOST POLLUTING SECTORS IN
THE STATE AND- PERHAPS ONE OF
THE MOST EXPLOITIVE OF ITS
WORKFORCE. BUT TO ITS CREDIT
THIS LEGISLATOR HAS PASSED THE
NUMBER OF BILLS TO CLEAN UP THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY. AND REDUCE
THE INSIDIOUS PRACTICE OF MIS
CLASSIFICATION THOSE EFFORTS
HAVE INCLUDED AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
AB FIVE AND SB THREE THREE
EIGHT. BUT DESPITE YOUR BEST
EFFORTS MISS CLASSIFICATION
REMAINS A PERVASIVE BUSINESS
PRACTICE WITHIN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY- AND THAT ARE NOT ONLY
EXPLOITS WORKERS BUT ALSO
IMPERILS OUR STATES- CLEAN
TRUCKING- GOALS. ARE BECAUSE
COMPANIES OFFLOAD THEIR
OPERATIONAL COSTS ONTO WORKERS
ARE MISCLASSIFIED CONTRACTORS
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH- THE STATE'S
CLEANER GOAL- AND THIS REALLY
PUTS A- HAMPER OWNERS THE-
ABILITY TO REALLY REACH THOSE
TARGETS. AB. TWENTY
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE WAY THE
TRUCKING OPERATIONS WORK- AND
CARD DATA BEARS THIS OUT AS THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
FULL PICTURE OF THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY IN THEIR CURRENT ROLE
MAKING. RBG ITSELF HAS A PUT OUT
A NUMBER OF REPORTS ON THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY SUBMITTED A
NUMBER OF- REQUEST FOR PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION I CAN
ATTEST TO THE LIMITATIONS OF
THOSE EXISTING DATA SETS. PLEASE
CONTINUE THIS LEGISLATORS-
RECORD OF PROTECTING EMPLOYEES
AND VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS SIZE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERYMUCH. ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
FAVOR AB. TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN. MR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SPORT THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBER STEVEN MYERS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD BE AT THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL AND WESTERN
STATES CONSERVE SHEET METAL
WORKERS WHO MAKE UP THE LABOR
PORTION OF THE BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LET A
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN IN LONDON ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT. AND WE NEED
TO HAVE ABOUT THREE IN THE QUEUE
LOCAL TO LINE A ONE OH TO PLEASE
WELL I HAD. THIS IS A MONTH.
CALIFORNIA SO VOTERS IN FORT.
THANK YOU. BUT COMPACT. BACK TO
THE HOTEL I THANK TWO PLEASE I
HAD. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MICHAEL- WITH THE
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR NEW
ECONOMY AND ALSO WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE CENTER
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ENACT THE MULTI LINE
A ONE OH ONE PEOPLE HAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS GETTING BEYOND
LOCUSTS RADIUS BOARD MEMBER WITH
LATINOS IN ACTION CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE PROBABLY SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND THAT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
. THANK YOU- BOOK WELCOME TO
OPPOSITION AND SO THE
PROPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO COME
ON UP TO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
FROM PATHFINDER AT MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE CHRISTIAN MODE OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN BUT WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS FOR REACHING OUT IN
VANCE OF THE HEARING LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
MISSUS OF BUILDING SORT OF THE
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
. MODERATOR TO CHECK ON THE
PHONE LINES. THEY WENT
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SEVEN. YES
THE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO NOW AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU. CORRECT
OVER THE BACK- TO THE COMMITTEE
. ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES A
MEASURE THE RESEARCHER I DO
JUST- YOU SAID THAT THERE WAS
NOT A SHORTAGE OF TRUCK DRIVERS-
YEAH THERE'S A NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE THE STATE'S THE AMERICAN
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION THERE'S
ACTUALLY SORT OF LIKE EIGHTY
THOUSAND. TRUCK DRIVERS AND SO
WHEN THE ONLINE IS THE ONLY
HISTORY SAYS THIS WE DEAL WITH
THIS ON A DAILY BASIS I AM
CURIOUS LIKE. IF THERE'S A
ROUGHLY SHORT OF EIGHTY THOUSAND
TRUCK DRIVERS BASED ON THAT
STUDY- HOW CAN WE SAY THAT
THERE'S NO SHORTAGE AND WHAT
DOES THIS BILL DO TO. ALLOW THE
BECAUSE I MEAN WE'VE ALL DEALT
WITH AB FIVE FOR A LITTLE WHILE
AND I THINK THIS BILL IS- IS
SIMPLY ANOTHER. QUITE FRANKLY
SHOT OF THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY-
TO GET IT UNDER HER ARM A LABOR
AGREEMENT. AND WHETHER WE HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT- IS NOT
WHAT I'M ORDER. AND ALLOW MY
CONCERN TODAY RIGHT NOW. BUT I
DO THINK. WITH EIGHTY THOUSAND.
VACANCIES ANYTHING THAT WE DO
TO. REDUCE THAT IS GOING TO BE
PROBLEMATIC. EVEN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CLEAN VEHICLES. RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NOT A VEHICLE OUT THERE
IT'S CLEAN. SO WHEN WE MOVED
THROUGH THESE POLICIES I THINK
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT THIS. AT A VERY HONEST
ABOUT THIS AND HAVE TO SLOW THIS
THING DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY JUST
NOT REALLY A- QUESTION I GUESS.
IS MORE JUST OF A STATEMENT LIKE
I JUST I HAD TO PUSH BACK I'M
SORRY JUST EVER SO GENTLY ON
THAT WE DO HAVE A- A SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGE OF TRUCK DRIVERS IN THE
COUNTRY. WHO ELSE. COMMON
QUESTIONS I BELIEVE WE NEED A
MOTION ON THOSE AS WELL. SIR
MOTION THANK THE- ALL RIGHT SO
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEASE SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND THIS IS
A BILL THAT I ALSO. I SAW IN
TRANSPORTATION AND AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD I DO BELIEVE THAT WE DO
NEED TO DO THAT CAN. SEARCH
INCREASED NUMBER OF TRUCKERS BUT
THEN THERE'S SOME LIMIT TO THAT
AND I THINK LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS
SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR- MOVE IN
OVER THE LINE- THERE IS AS WELL
AS A- NOBODY CAN. OF THE PORTS
ARE CRITICAL BOTH IN TERMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF SUPPLY CHAIN.
AND THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO KIND OF WORK ON BOTH
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH WITH WORKERS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS EVERYBODY ON
BOARD AND SO WITH THAT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL- HE IS A MEMBER
COMMUNITIES LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
THANK YOU- WELL I FIRST LET ME
JUST SAY- I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ON A ON THE- WHAT
APPEARS TO BE- A LACK OR-
SHORTAGE. OF TRUCK DRIVERS WE
HAVE DONE A LOT OF WORK TO
ENSURE THAT INDEPENDENCE
MISCLASSIFIED TRUCK DRIVERS ALSO
HAVE ACCESS TO. ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT THE STATE IS
PUTTING FORWARD TO CREATE CLEAN
ENERGY VEHICLES THAT MOVE ACROSS
THE STATE THE MOVE FROM THE
PORTS THAT GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
WAREHOUSES. UNFORTUNATELY MISS
CLASSIFICATION OFTEN LEADS TO
THE FACT THAT AN INDEPENDENT
TRUCK DRIVERS DON'T GET ACCESS
TO THESE RESOURCES. SO WHILE WE
HAVE. CREATED INCREDIBLE CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS THAT HAVE LED THE
NATION IN OUR LEADING THE WORLD
QUITE QUITE FRANKLY. WE ALSO
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE WORK
FORCE- AND THE INDIVIDUALS AND
THE PEOPLE IN THE WORKING
FAMILIES THAT ACTUALLY. MOVE
THESE GOODS ACROSS OUR STATE
HAVE ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
THAT WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS- WE
HAVE LABOR WE HAVE BUSINESS WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS
THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING THIS
RIGHT. IT IS WHY I HAVE ACTIVELY
REACHED OUT TO OPPOSITION TO SAY
WE NEED YOU AT THE TABLE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING THIS
RIGHT AND THAT YOU ARE INCLUDED
IN THE CONVERSATION. I FEEL LIKE
THE APPROACH THAT WE HAVE AND
THAT WE HAVE HAD. A WITH THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT BILLS THAT WE
HAVE DONE AROUND THE SECTOR. IS
PROVING THAT THERE IS A WAY TO
HAVE BOTH THERE IS A WAY THAT WE
CAN HAVE- LABOR STANDARDS THAT
ARE BEING. ADHERED TO. THAT
WORKERS TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT WE AND
THE MISS CLASSIFICATION OF A
WORK FORCE THAT DOES NOT RECEIVE
SEVERAL BENEFITS. THAT ARE
ENTITLED TO THEM AS CURSING AND
THAT ULTIMATELY CALIFORNIA IS
SETTING. THE TRUE PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW DEAL THAT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES CLIMATE
CHANGE. CLIMATE JUSTICE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT JUST
TRANSITION AND SETS THE TONE NOT
ONLY FOR OUR STATE. BUT FOR THE
NATION ACTUALLY MAKE THAT A
REALITY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY AND
CALL THE ROLL ON AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA NUMBER JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I REYES.
REYES EYES ZERO ZERO KNOWN WARD
. LEE THE I. LETS THOSE OUT AND
WE CAN MOVE ON TO ITEM TWELVE
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AB. TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE FORTY THREE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE PREVAILING WAGE FOR
SOLAR PROJECTS OVER FIFTEEN
KILOWATTS THAT OPT INTO THE NET
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM IN WOULD
REQUIRE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON ROOFTOP SOLAR ADOPTION
BY. SISTER AND ZIP CODE THAT'S
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
THE LEAD ENTITY TO REGULATE
UTILITIES AND ACT ON BEHALF OF
RATE PAYERS AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE AND THEY'VE USE THAT
MANDATE TO CREATE GENEROUS
INCENTIVES FOR ROUTE. FOURNETTE
HAS LED. WHAT THEY WHEN STATE
AUTHORITY IS BEING USED TO
CREATE AN INCENTIVE THAT BENEFIT
SOME OF THE COST OTHERS IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON THE LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AND MAKE
SURE THAT A PUBLIC BENEFIT IS
BEING DERIVED MEMBERS LET ME BE
CLEAR THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
MAKING CHANGES TO THE TERROR OF
OFFERED BY NET ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM RATHER THIS BILL IS TWO
THINGS THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS SEE A
RETURN. ON AN INCENTIVE CREATED
ON BEHALF IT IS A REALITY THAT
SOLAR INSTALLERS ARE NOT PAID AS
MUCH AS OTHER ELECTRICAL FIRST.
THERE ARE AN EXAMPLES FROM THE
LAST DECADE OF LARGE COMPANIES
THAT HAVE USE INNOVATION AS AN
EXCUSE TO DRIVE DOWN WAGES. FROM
RIDE SHARE TO WORK HOUSE WORK
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SEEN IT ALL.
WE CAN'T ACCEPT THIS IN A GLEAM
IN A CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A WORLD
LEADER IN A CLEAN GREEN ENERGY.
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD NOT ONLY
INVESTMENTS BUT ALSO ON THE
PLANNING NECESSARY TO GET 21100%
RENEWABLE BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THAT BILL SB ONE HUNDRED WHICH I
CO AUTHORED MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK
NECESSARY TO REDUCE OUR STATE'S
CONCEPTIONS OF FOSSIL FUELS AND
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION REGARDING. THE WORK
FORCE WITHIN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY. AS THE STATE MOVES
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS A NEW
DRILLING OR FRACKING INCENTIVES
TOWARDS RENEWAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
MUST INCLUDE. AT AT D. THIS BILL
WILL LOCK IN FOR COME. FOR
DOLLARS WORKING ON LARGE
PROJECTS THAT OP INTO THE PUBLIC
PROVIDED BENEFITS OF NAM. THE
OTHER ACTION THIS BILL WILL TAKE
ADDRESSES A NEED FOR GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND COMMUNITY
INCLUSION AROUND THE BENEFITS OF
NET ENERGY METERING. RIGHT NOW
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA ON
ROOFTOP SOLAR UPTAKE-
NEIGHBORHOOD BY NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHAT WE DO KNOW FROM UC BERKELEY
STUDY IN FROM THE PUC'S OWN
REPORT ON AFFORDABILITY IS THAT
RATEPAYERS IN UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. ARE MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM THEM AND
THAT THE KASHIF MAKES THE RATE
BURDEN HIGHER. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ONLY TO. THE REBATES WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE WENT TO
AFFORDABLE OR MULTI HOUSING
UNITS A HOUSING. HOW CAN WE
ADDRESS DISPARITIES IF WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW THEM- AND DON'T KNOW
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT THEY
EXIST. AVAILABLE HERE TO TESTIFY
ON THIS BILL WILL BENEFIT
WORKERS UNDER READ UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES HAS GOT
WEDGED. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL.
THANK. REMEMBER THAT WHICH HAVE
TO ASSOCIATION FOR CAL. OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES LET ME TO THIS
BILL. BOTH PARTS. THE ENERGY
POLICY PARTICULAR THE SOLAR CITY
CAL IS THE MOST WOULD. POLICY
THAT WE HAVE- AS REFERENCED BY
THE AUTHOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPENT THREE BILLION%
DOLLARS ON THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
INITIATIVE KNOWN AS THE HONORS
COURSE **** MILLION SOLAR ROOFS.
WE SPENT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
LESS THAN 2% OF THAT WENT TO
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSING- OR-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- THE
VAST MAJORITY THAT MONEY WENT TO
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL AND-
MARKET RATE HOUSING. IN WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES THE NET METERING
PROGRAM. HAS BUILT TWELVE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR THAT'S HUGELY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM. THE MEGA WATTS. IN ON
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES YOU MIGHT ASK LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OUT
OF TWELVE THOUSAND. THE HAAS
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS AT UC
BERKELEY. CONDUCTED A STUDY LAST
YEAR THAT FOUND THAT BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES TO ROOFTOP
SOLAR EVEN WHEN YOU ADJUST FOR
INCOME. WHAT'S THAT TELL YOU
REDLINING IS HAPPENING A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES. THE
FIRST PORTION OF THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT YOU GET A REPORT
EVERY YEAR THE BREAKS DOWN WHERE
THE SOLAR INSTALLATIONS ARE
HAPPENING ON A CENSUS TRACT
BASIS TO EACH MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SAY WHY IS MY
COMMUNITY NOT BEING SERVED OR-
WIRE PARTS MAKING ME NOT BEING
SIR. SECONDLY THE BILL WOULD
APPLY PREVAILING WAGE ON JUST.
THE VERY LARGEST- ROOFTOP SOLAR
PROJECTS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE NEW M. PROGRAM. OKAY THE
BILL WOULD WOULD AFFECT 3% OF
ALL ROOFTOP SOLAR ARRAYS BECAUSE
WE THREAT PUT THE THRESHOLD AT
FIFTEEN KILOWATT HOURS. WHEN YOU
PUT ROOF TOP SOLAR ON YOUR
BUSINESS OR ON YOUR HOME. YOU
RECEIVE TAX CREDITS YOU RECEIVE
A PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION. YOU
MOST YOU YOU ALSO RECEIVE. A
FULL RETAIL RATE FOR THE ENERGY
THAT YOU PRODUCE THAT EVERY
OTHER REPAIR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO DOESN'T HAVE
SOLAR PAYS OVER TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE TO YOU- THIS
IS A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF SUBSIDY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT
RISES TO THE LEVEL WHERE WE
SHOULD REQUIRE PREVAILING WAGE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE ALL THE
JOBS HAVE BEEN LOST IN THE HEAVY
EMITTING INDUSTRIES UNDER AB
THIRTY TWO- THE JOBS THAT WERE
CREATED TO REPLACE ALL THOSE
GOOD PAYING JOBS HAVE PER
MERRILY BEEN ROOFTOP SOLAR. UC
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER DID A
STUDY THAT FOUND THAT THE
AVERAGE- SOLAR INSTALLER INSTEAD
A CALIFORNIA MAKES NEARLY TWENTY
ONE DOLLARS AN HOUR TOTAL
PACKAGE LAST POINT JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO THE CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD. COMMISSION TO STUDY. THAT
FOUND IN THAT STUDY THEY FOUND
THAT IF YOU WERE TO ADD
PREVAILING WAGE. TO ROOFTOP
SOLAR ON THE FRONT END IT WOULD
INCREASE THE COST BY 325% BUT
THE STUDY WENT ON. TO CONCLUDE
THAT BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER
SKILLED WORK FORCE THAT THAT
NEGLIGIBLE INCREASE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE NEGATED THAT WASN'T
IN I. B. W. STUDY THAT WAS A
STUDY WAS COMMISSIONED BY STATE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD. FOR ALL THE ABOVE REASONS
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE AND WILL BE
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR CHARMERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND SPORT THANK
YOU. THEY WERE ON THE PHONE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT PRESS THE
ONE THEN THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX B. Q.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES GO
AHEAD NINE SIX ONE TWO. FIFTY TO
MEDITATE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BASED ON THE BALLOT HE
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS RESIST SENATE
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TO ALIGNMENT OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE ENGINEERS THANK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LOCAL TWENTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIELINE ONE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OUR DEFENSE CHIU
FOUNDER FOR INDIVISIBLE ROCK
VALLEY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
. MAXIMALIST A LOT BY NOW THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR.
AND THANK GOD FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. R.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE I THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KIM STONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL BUT STRONG-
OPPOSITION- I WANT TO REFER YOU
TO- WAS A JOINT AGENCY REPORT
PUT OUT BY THAT- CARB THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OFF. OPERATOR IF YOU SEE
AN OFFICE- AND OPR CALLED AT THE
ELECTRICITY SYSTEM OF THE FUTURE
AT LAST FALL AND IT MENTIONED-
THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL CLEAN
ENERGY GENERATION GOING FORWARD
JUSTICE OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CO AUTHORED AND WE NEED CLEAN
ENERGY GROWTH IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR S. B. ONE HUNDRED GREENHOUSE
GAS FOR TEN GOALS. THAT REPORT
STATED THAT SOLAR- RATES MEAN
NEED TO NEARLY TRIPLE AND
BATTERY STORAGE BUILD RATES NEED
TO INCREASE BY NEARLY EIGHT FULL
THIS IS NOT THE TIME AS WE
BECOME INCREASINGLY ELECTRIFIED
TO PUT THE BRAKES ON THE GROWTH
OF SOLAR AND THIS BILL WOULD
SLOW DOWN- ARE CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS IT WOULD LIKELY INCREASE
THE USE OF FOSSIL FUELS. AND-
CALLING AND OTHER BASED PRIVATE
ENDEAVOR IF THE HARDWARE STORE
OR- THE RESTAURANTS- PUTS OF
SOLAR PANELS ON ITS PARKING LOT
YOU KNOW OF A LARGER SIZE THAN
THAN YOU WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW IN
A TYPICAL RESIDENTIAL THAT DOES
NOT MAKE. THAT PROJECT- A PUBLIC
WORK AND IMPOSING THE
COMPLICATED REALLY SORT OF
BYZANTINE REQUIREMENTS ON DOING
A PUBLIC WORK WE HAVE MEMBERS
WHO HAVE DONE- PUBLIC WORKS AND
THERE'S NOT. EVEN A
CLASSIFICATION FOR A SOLAR
INSTALLER- FOR DOING THAT WORK
IT'S VERY- BURDENSOME PUTS ON
TRUMP ANNOUNCED- OF RED TAPE AND
WILL MAKE IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
FOR OUR OVER SEVEN HUNDRED. US
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WHAT SMALL
AND LARGE BUSINESSES CHEWING-
SOLAR INSTALLATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
SOLAR INSTALLATION MORE
EXPENSIVE PARTICULARLY IN OUR
INLAND REGIONS IT WILL- THE-
SOLAR MARKET IS BECOMING
INCREASING LEE- ACCESSIBLE TO
MIDDLE AND LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
AND THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO
RAISE THE COST JUSTICE- THE
TELEMARKETERS BECOMING MORE
ACCESSIBLE. WEEK THEREFORE MUST
RESPECTFULLY- OPPOSE THE BILL
THIS IS. SORT OF A DIFFERENT
VERSION OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE- FROM LAST YEAR. I AND THE
SOLAR. IS HONESTLY FIGHTING FOR
ITS SURVIVAL- ON MULTIPLE FRONTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO
SURVIVE- FOR ALL OF US AND FOR
OUR FUTURE. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN OPPOSITION. AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON PAUL WOODS WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
pTHE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AT A MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE. BURNSAP ADDITION A
FUND AND THEY WROTE. AND WE WILL
BOOK THE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES. HI
JENNIFER TANNER ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND VOTERS FROM
THE TWENTY TWO GROUPS THAT
SIGNED THE INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN CAN LETTER
OPPOSING AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE YOU ALL HAVE THAT LETTER
WITH OUR ARGUMENT WE
RESPECTFULLY PARTICULARLY
OPPOSED TO ANTI CLIMATE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. REVOKED A
LOT NUMBER EIGHTY TWO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO. STEPHANIE
BROWN ON BEHALF OF TOGETHERWE
WILL INDIVISIBLE MONTHS CONDOS
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE OH SEVEN. IF IT'S A
REBEKAH ELLIOTT WITH INDIVISIBLE
SANTA FE OF THE CALIFORNIA EIGHT
BRONX INDIVISIBLE GROUPS AND
INDIVISIBLE GREENSTEIN WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
THE KEIRA MISTER CHAIR I HAD.
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU
STILL NEED A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. I WOULD JUST SAY
LOOK- YES SIMILARLY. I JUST
THINK IT'S GONNA THANK THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS BILL FORD AND
I THINK IT'S A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE DEPLOYED SOLAR
MAKE SURE MORE PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO ADOPT SOLAR ALSO BENEFITING
FROM THE NEW IN INDUSTRY I THINK
IT'S A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH BELL
OF COURSE I REPRESENT A
CONSTITUENCY THAT ROOFTOP SOLAR
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THAT AND I'VE OFFICE BUYERS
LAWYER WITH TOP OWNERS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TAT WHILE
THEY'RE DOING THAT. TO PAY
WORKERS FAILING I DO HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT WHY WE'RE USING
THE PUBLIC WORKS CODE I DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND AS BY OUR
REGION PUBLIC WORKS IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND IT'S MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S WILL BE
BUILDINGS I JUST WONDERING. WHY
PROTESTS AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU- DID THE MISNOMER THIS
IS- I THINK THE IMPLICATION THE
THAT WITNESSES IN UP WAS. THAT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE MAKE
EVERY INSTALLATION OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR THAT QUALIFIES A PUBLIC
WORKS. ALL PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
PAY PREVAILING WAGE ALL PROJECTS
WERE PREVAILING WAGES REQUIRED
ARE NOT NECESSARILY PUBLIC WORKS
WHEN YOU'RE A PUBLIC WORKS THAT
BRINGS INTO INTOIT YOU KNOW
THERE'S APPRENTICESHIP
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S A
COMPETITIVE BID LOW BID
REQUIREMENTS ALL THOSE THINGS
THIS BILL DOESN'T TOUCH ANY OF
THAT. THIS BILL DOES THE CITIES
ARE GOING TO BE PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS IT SAYS THE PREVAILING
WAGES SHALL APPLY OKAY THAT'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE IT JUST GETS TO
THE WAGES AND BENEFITS THAT ARE
PAID TO THE WORKERS INTERNS THAT
ARE INSTALLING THEM. AND AGAIN
IT ONLY APPLIES TO PROJECTS OF
FIFTEEN K. W. IN LARGER WITCHER
3% OF ALL THE ROOFTOP SOLAR
THESE ARE THE LARGEST OF THE
LARGE RIGHT SO THIS ISN'T. AS WE
SORT OF INTIMATED. SOMEWHAT MOM
AND POP SMALL LITTLE YOU KNOW
HOMEOWNERS SETTLED WITH THIS IS
EITHER GOING TO BE REALLY. LARGE
REYES. YOU'RE A IS IT SEVENTY.
PANELS OKAY THINK ABOUT HOW
BIG'S PANELS IS SIXTY NINE
ACTUALLY BUT CLOSE ENOUGH- SO IT
IT DOESN'T DESIGNATE THESE
PROJECTS AS PUBLIC WORKS IN THE
TOTAL DEFINITION OF WHAT A
PUBLIC WORKS AS IT JUST APPLIES
PREVAILING WAGE. THANK YOU FOR
OUR PATIENT ALSO POINTING OUT
THE EQUITY APPOINTED TO IT'S
ABOUT LARGE SOLAR ARRAYS AND NOT
JUST THE AVERAGE COUPLE SOLAR
ARRAYS THAT EVEN OUR FEATURED
MY- HOME DISTRICT SO I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER THANK YOU
. AND I WOULD ALSO ADD- TO JUST.
SOME OF THE COMMENTARY ON ON
FOLKS CALLING IN IN OPPOSITION
THIS HAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP
SOLAR WHICH WAS THE PREVIOUS
VERSIONS. OF THE BILLS THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD SO
TO MAKE A STATEMENT THAT. THIS
IS A DIFFERENT VERSION OF THAT
BILL IT'S NOT THAT BILL AT ALL-
IN FACT WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THE
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS WAS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA NECESSARY
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY.
ENSURE ONE FIRST AND FOREMOST AT
THIRTY IN THE CONVERSATION OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND SOLAR. SO
WHILE THIS PERTAINS TO LARGE
SCALE ROOFTOP SOLAR. IF YOU ARE
A- MULTI MANSION MAC MANSION
OWNER. WHY ARE YOU TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A SUBSIDY THAT
ACTUALLY IMPACTS LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND RENTERS. IN THE
REPORT- THAT ACTUALLY WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY THE P. UC TITLED-
UTILITY COSTS IN THE
AFFORDABILITY OF THE GRID OF THE
FUTURE. THE REPORT ITSELF
THROUGH AN AND DIDN'T STUDY.
CLEARLY LAID OUT THAT. THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR INITIATIVE THAT WE
HAVE NOW THROUGH MA'AM THAT THE
P. YOU SEE HAS FAILED TO ACT TO
REFORM. HAS BENEFITED WHITE AND
WEALTHY HOMEOWNERS AT THE COST
AND THE COST SHIFT OF RENTERS
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THIS IS WHY WE ARE NOT
INITIALLY TOP- ACTUALLY. DOING
IT RELATED TO RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP BUT WE ARE REQUIRING THE
P. YOU SEE TO HAVE AN ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
NOT ONLY SPEAKS TO SIP COATS.
BUT THE CENSUS TRACKS THAT WILL
GIVE US THE DATA NECESSARY ON
ETHNICITY AND INCOME TO ENSURE
THAT MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE THE
REPORTS NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO DO EQUITY WHEN IT COMES
TO RENEWABLE ENERGY. SO THE
CONVERSATION AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CLIMATE JUSTICE AND
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION ON THE
GREEN NEW DEAL INCLUDES A PILLAR
THAT SAYS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND CLIMATE JUSTICE MUST
INCLUDE. A TRANSITIONAL
WORKFORCE FOR CLEAN GREEN
RENEWABLE ENERGY JOBS SO YOU
CAN'T SAY LESS SHUTDOWN FOSSIL
FUELS BUT LET'S ALSO NOT PAY
WORKERS THE RATE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE PAYING TO MAKE A
LIVING WAGE AND BE ABLE TO LOOK
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION. THESE CONVERSATIONS GO
HAND IN HAND YOU CAN BE A
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLIMATE
JUSTICE ACTIVISTS AND YOU SHOULD
BE A LABOR ADVOCATE IN THE LABOR
ACTIVE- ACTIVIST AS WELL YOU CAN
BE. TRADITIONALLY YOU ARE BOTH
YOU CANNOT SAY THAT YOU ONLY
CARE ABOUT CLIMATE AND THEN NOT
CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT YOU ALLEGEDLY ARE TRYING TO
SAVE. SO THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
COMPLICATED THEY ARE. NEW
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE ARE HAVING
AS WE'RE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
WAY IN WHICH WE TALK ABOUT
ENERGY AND THE WAY THAT WE-
BRING IN A NEW. CLEAN GREEN
ENERGY WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT HAS ALL THE BENEFITS TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN THE STATE AND TO
LIVE WITH DIGNITY THIS IS WHY
LABOR IS A BIG PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THIS IS WHY. AT THE
BARE MINIMUM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PREVAILING WAGE THAT'S THE
MINIMUM THAT'S THE FLOOR THAT'S
NOT THE CEILING THAT'S THE
FLOOR. SO WE ARE IN A IN A NEW
SPACE- AND I HOPE THAT YOU KNOW
AS WE CONTINUE MOVING THE
CONVERSATION FORWARD THAT WE
HAVE CLIMATE CHANGE ACTIVISTS
AND CLIMATE ADVOCATES UNDERSTAND
THE NECESSITY TO BRING IN LABOR
AND TO BRING IN WORKERS INTO THE
CONVERSATION AND- WEBER. THANK I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND YOU
KNOW BACK DISTRICT SPA THE
CLARITY OF IT DOES NOT CHANGE.
THE DEFINITION PUBLIC WORKS IN
TERMS OF THE KIND OF ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE ENGAGED IN THAT. THAT
THAT MAKE A PUBLIC WAS JUST THE
PURPOSE OF PAYMENT. OF THE
PREVAILING WAGE IS SOMETHING
SOMEBODY TO BUILD THE BUILDING
TRADES PEERS AGO THAT TO DO WITH
THE SUBSIDIES- SOME OF WHICH
WENT. TO DEVELOPERS ARE BUILDING
HOUSING OR OTHER KINDS OF
PROJECTS- WE WERE JUST. FOCUSING
ON PREVAILING WAGE MAKING SURE
LOOK AT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. THE
TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES SUBSIDY ABOUT
SIZE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
CONDITIONS ON THE KIND OF WORK
PRODUCT THAT'S COMING FROM THAT-
AND SO LOOK THIS ISSUE. HAS
CONTINUED TO COME UP AS AN
ENTITY TO COME UP. AND THERE ARE
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT. INTERESTS AND- NOT
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE BUILDING
BUILDING AND PUTTING UP THE-
SOLAR PANELS ON YOUR THEY HAVE
AN INTERESTIN IT- YOU HAVE. THE
WORKERS AND THOSE REPRESENTING
THE WORKERS HAVE AN INTEREST IN
IT. YOU HAVE THE ACADEMICS- THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD WITH THE RAW
DATA AND- OF THE- INDEPENDENT
DATA TELLING US WHAT'S
HAPPENING. YOU HAVE THE
ACTIVISTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS THE WORKERS AND YET
THE ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS-
THAT ARE SAYING LOOK WE HAVE TWO
MORE BECAUSE WE DO EVERYBODY
AGREES WE HAVE TO DO MORE- BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY- IT. IT
DOESN'T. DO US GOOD. IF WE'RE
FOCUSED SO MUCH OF THESE ARE
LARGE PROJECTS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW. OKAY YOU'RE TALKING
MONTHS ALMOST SEVENTY PANEL SO
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SOLAR INSTALLATION.
I HAVE A LOT MY DISTRICT I ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF POOR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE ALMOST ZERO. IN MY
DISTRICT YEAH A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIVE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. ARE
THE ONES ON THE ROOF PUTTING UP.
THE PANELS. ARE MAKING CLOSE TO
MINIMUM WAGE. AND SO WE HAVE TO
COULD BE CONCERNED EQUALLY ABOUT
BOTH THE WE- AND SO. I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A THAT I'M IS ARTISTS OF
THE EXPANSION SOLAR POWER POWER
SYSTEM. MANY YEARS IN THE
COUNCIL AND I CONTINUE TO BE.
BUT WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
CONDITIONS OF THE WORKERS. THAT
ARE PUTTING UP THOSE PANELS ON
THESE AGAINST LARGE PROJECTS AND
THE DATA COLLECTION IS CRITICAL
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE DO WITH
THE REST. RIGHT BECAUSE WE NEED
THAT DAY ALL OF US SEE THAT
DATA. TO FIGURE OUT. IF THE
PROGRAM COULD BE DONE BETTER
DONE DIFFERENTLY- IT'S BEEN A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM LIKE A LOT OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES INITIALLY IT'S
THOSE A HOW THE WEALTH. LOGICAL
CARS OR EXAMPLE DOES HAVE THE
RESOURCES ARE ABLE TO BE THE FOR
EARLY ADOPTERS BUT WE CANNOT BE
SUCCESSFUL UNTIL WE GET
EVERYONE. THE ABILITY TO ADOPT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND IN THE
MEANTIME. THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MAKING THOSE TECHNOLOGIES AND
INSTALLING THEM. NEEDED HAVE
WORKED WITH DIGNITY AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A GREAT.%
FIRST STEP I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE INCLUDING MY DEAR
FRIENDS INDIVISIBLE TO RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE OF THE WORKERS AND HOW
WE CAN COME TOGETHER. AND
RECOGNIZE. THESE LARGE PRIVATE.
COMMERCIAL PROJECTS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE LARGE SCALE THESE ARE
PEOPLE OF WEALTH WHETHER IT'S-
YOU KNOW. A LARGE COMMERCIAL
COMPLEX WHICH WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO ENCOURAGE. MORE SOLAR. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME LET'S THINK ABOUT
WHO'S ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK TO
PUT THE SOLAR PANELS UP THERE.
SO THE DOES THIS AS A JOINT I
RECOMMENDATION- BUT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANY FURTHER CLOSING
COMMENTS. I THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FOR THAT AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE INDULGENCE OF THE
CONVERSATION- I HAVE THE LUXURY
AND PRIVILEGE ACTUALLY I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE TO SERVE ON ENERGY
AND UTILITIES AND THIS HAS BEEN.
ON THE ENERGY UTILITIES
COMMITTEE. AND WE CONTINUE TO
SEE VARIOUS DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES TO.
CALIFORNIA REACHING ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS- IN LABOR COMMITTEE
AND AS AS AS A STUDENT OF LABOR.
YOU KNOW I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK
OF THE ORIGINAL. ENERGY
PRODUCERS COAL MINERS. WHEN WE
TRANSITIONED FROM COAL TO
NATURAL GAS THERE WAS A SECTOR
OF WORKERS THAT WAS LEFT BEHIND
. SO WE TRANSITION TO NATURAL
GAS AND NOW WE ARE TRANSITIONING
TO SOLAR TO WIND TO GEO THERMAL
AND A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY THE
CONVERSATION I'M ON THE WORK
FORCE NEEDS TO BE FRONT AND
CENTER TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT
LEAVING ANY WORKER BEHIND AND
THEN AS WE ACHIEVE OUR RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS WE ARE
TRANSITIONING WITH THE FACE OF
DIGNITY. EQUITY AND GOOD PAYING
JOBS THAT ACTUALLY ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO LIVE AND THRIVE
IN CALIFORNIA AT THE MINIMUM AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I WILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MADAM SECRETARY BEGIN TAKING
THE WALL. ROLL CALL VOTE ON. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. SORRY
THAT WAS ONE OF THE CONSENT
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA NOT BOOTING
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I
REYES SEYARTO ZERO NO WARD. LEAK
HI THE I WHAT'S THE BILL WILL BE
PLACE ON CALL THANK YOU. AND I
DON'T FOURTEEN. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE SEIRA BONTA.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE THE
PROMOTE OWNERSHIP BY WORKERS FOR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OR THE POWER
ACT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
ASSOCIATION OF COOPERATIVE LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO PROMOTE EQUITABLE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT REDUCE
INEQUALITY AND CREATE
SUSTAINABLE PATHWAYS TO LIVING
WAGE JOBS THROUGH WORKER OWNED
COOPERATIVES. THE STRUCTURE OF
WORKER COOPS REQUIRES EXTENSIVE
LEGAL TAX AND GOVERNANCE
EXPERTISE PRESENTING A HUGE COST
AND BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR ENTRY
ENTERPRISING WORKERS AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY NINE SEEKS TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD BY REDUCING
BARRIERS FOR WORKER CORPS BY
ESTABLISHING A VOLUNTARY MEMBER
BASED MUTUAL BENEFIT CORPORATION
TO ASSIST IN THEIR FORMATION AND
OPERATION. THE ASSOCIATION OF
COOPERATIVE LABOR CONTRACTORS
WILL SERVE AS A WORKER DIRECTED
RESOURCE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ALLOW FOR
ECONOMIES OF SCALE FOR PAYROLL
AND OTHER TECH A TYPICAL
EMPLOYER FUNCTIONS MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION ELECT TO MEET
HIGH MINIMUM LABOR STANDARDS ON
WAGES PAY TRANSPARENCY
RETIREMENT SAVINGS HEALTHCARE
AND OTHER BITS AND IN EXCHANGE
THEY RECEIVE STATE AND LOCAL TAX
RELIEF CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CREDIT UNION LAWS.
AS WELL AS SOME JOINT
EMPLOYMENT. RELIEF AS ARE UNEVEN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY CONTINUES AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE GIVES
WORKERS THE POWER TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF THEIR FUTURE AND
PROVIDE A MORE INCLUSIVE
PROSPERITY THROUGH CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND AS A WITNESS WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE. DINI'S TO
GANDHI WITH THIS FCAU YOU REACH
UP YOU. THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS
DENISE MCCARTY THE SECOND PLEASE
THANK YOU- WITH SEIU UNITED
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WORKER
COOPERATIVES PRESENT AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND
PATHWAYS TO LIVING WAGE JOBS
WITH BENEFITS. WHILE ALSO HAVING
A SAY IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
BUSINESS THIS MODEL IS NOT ONLY
GOOD FOR WORKERS. BUT ALSO HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE MORE ABLE TO
WEATHER ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS THAN
TRADITIONALLY INCORPORATED
BUSINESSES. A SLICE OF NEW YORK
IS ONE OF ONLY FIVE CO OPS IN
THE SOUTH BAY AND THE ONLY
RETAIL COOP IN THE SOUTH BAY.
BOTH A SLICE OF NEW YORK AND
YEAH YOU YOU W. ARE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE WORKER OWN
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA COALITION.
WORKER OWNERS AND A SLICE OF NEW
YORK CREATED THE ORGANIZATION'S
FIRST PTO PLAN A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE POLICY OF FOUR OH ONE K.
PLAN- AND PRIORITIZE HEALTH AND
SAFETY DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. ALLOWING THEM TO STAY
OPEN SAFELY. AS KIRK BARTON A
SLICE OF NEW YORK'S GENERAL
MANAGER AND FOUNDER HAS SHARED.
WELL WE HAD OUR FIVE YEAR COOP
ANNIVERSARY THIS PAST JULY THERE
ARE MANY AREAS OF FRUSTRATION.
THE PROFESSIONAL SERVICES WORLD
LIKE ATTORNEYS ACCOUNTANTS
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS DON'T
KNOW WHAT COOPS ARE OR HOW TO
PROPERLY SUPPORT THEM. EVERY
YEAR I NEED TO BATTLE WITH MY
INSURANCE COMPANY FOR LITERALLY
MONTHS WHEN THEY PERFORM THEIR
WORKERS COMPENSATION AUDIT. THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT PATRONAGE IS OR
HOW IT APPLIES TO THEIR POLICIES
OR CREDIT CARD COMPANIES THAT
REQUIRE A PERSONAL GUARANTEE ON
A COMPANY. EVEN THOUGH IT IS NOT
A MAJORITY OWNER- OR THE
COMMERCIAL LANDLORD THAT WANTS.
TO CONTINUE MY PERSONAL
GUARANTEE. WITHOUT MORE
AWARENESS AND PROGRAMS THESE
CHALLENGES WILL NOT GET
ADDRESSED. STATE INVESTMENT AND
SUPPORT OF THE HYBRID MODEL
WOULD BE OF GREAT PUBLIC BENEFIT
PAVING THE WAY FOR MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY. THANK YOU AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON THE
MEASURE THANK YOU IS ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SPORT THANK YOU. REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH ESCAPE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A MODERATOR'S NAME ON THE PHONE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE. YOUR PARTNER IS ONE NINE
ZERO. BARELY THE BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR. WE PHILLIP ON
BEHALF OF THE PLAN THE NEW YORK
AND PROJECT EQUITY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. DO NOT HAVE ANY
MARQUITA IN ORDER. THANK YOU I
HAD. OKAY AND WILL COME. ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION IS NOT
PRIMARY WHEN HIS OPPOSITION TO
IN THE ROOM. ABOUT A MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE. APPOSITION AND IT'S
ONE NINE TWO ZERO. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION AT THE TIME
OKAY THANK YOU SOBERLY. THANK
YOU FOR THIS BILL- WE'RE CLUB
WORKER CLUB CIRCLE THIS BILLS
FOR IF I COULD BE ADDED TO
COOPER THAT WOULD BE COOL THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. WHAT'S MORE
THEY GOT A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
SPACE I'M REALLY GRATEFUL THAT
THAT- AND PERSONAL LEGISLATION
YOUR TANKARD BARTON IN FACT WHEN
I HAD WE HAD INFO HEARING ON
WILL TO COOPER'S RECORD AS WELL
AS REPRESENTED AS HOW YOU SPOKE-
BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS THE THINKING ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF WORK THE WORKER COOPERATIVES-
SHOULD AND MUST BE A PART OF IT
AND IT IS AN NEW TERRITORY FOR A
LOT OF THESE INSTITUTIONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND DEPARTMENTS-
FIVE STATE AND OTHERWISE COUNTY
WHAT HAVE YOU THAT AREN'T.
ACCUSTOMED TO WORK WITH THEM SO
I'M I'M REALLY GRATEFUL- THAT
YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
LEGISLATION THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE- YOU KNOW ONCE- WE GET THIS
ACT PASSED- I THINK IT'LL BE
FOUNDATION FOR A LOT MORE OF
LEGISLATION AND BOB DOLE PAUL
HE'S GOING FOR THAT ARE GOING TO
HELP- THEY'RE GONNA HELP COOPER
IS TO GROW AND EXPAND AND ONE OF
THE AREAS WHERE YOU KNOW WHERE
IT'S BEEN CRITICAL IN SILICON
VALLEY IN THE MARION'S CERTAINLY
PROBABLY OTHER PARTS THE STATE.
IS A LOT OF FIRST GENERATION
IMMIGRANTS TO COME HERE AND
START RESTAURANTS I'VE SEEN THIS
HAPPEN NUMEROUS TIMES AND- SEND
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE AND THEY
GO UP INTO THE CHRISTIAN WE
DON'T WANT TO COME BACK IN THE
FAMILY BUSINESS AND THEY'VE
CREATED TENTH WHAT TWENTY THIRTY
pTHIS BUSINESS AND THEY JUST SELL
IT EVEN THOUGH THE MANAGERS THE
WORKERS THE DISHWASHERS AND
COOKS PROBABLY COULD TAKE OVER
THE BUSINESS OF THE WAS THE
CAPACITY AND KNOWLEDGE BASE TO
DO THAT WHICH TO OUR
ORGANIZATION TO DO BUT WE HAVE
TO HELP FACILITATE THAT. AND
THAT'S PART OF. OKAY AS- TO THE
- CAN PICK UP- MET WITH PICK
THESE BUSINESS UP. AND THEM
GENERAL. WITH WORKERS IN CAN AND
SO- VERY GOOD TO YOU BY THIS
FLOOR WE DO HAVE A- FROM SIR FOR
A SECOND. BY SUMMER LEAVE A I TO
CLOSE. THE YOU SO MUCH MISS LEE
YOU CALL I THANK YOU FOR.
OFFERING TO CO AUTHORED IT WILL
TAKE YOU UP ON THAT-
ENTREPRENEURS EVERY SINGLE DAY
TRYING TO STRUGGLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN BRING FORWARD
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPORT OUR
ECONOMIES AND OFTEN THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. THAT WITH
PEOPLE THAT THEY CARE ABOUT AND
TOGETHER AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT ALLOWS
WORKER COOPS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT SO I REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR INTEREST IN THIS AND I
RESPECT. HERE I. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE- ADDAMS. CAN TAKE. A
THE ROLE- A. TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I REYES REYES I'D
SAY OR DON'T SEYARTO NO WORD. WE
HI LEAI THOSE OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY THERE SOME BILLS
ON CALL GOING TO START WITH
THOSE IN THE NAPA THAT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND DO ADAMS. SO STARTING
WITH. HEIDEMANN RIGHT NOT. AB
SIXTEEN FORTY THREE ITEM ONE IS
AB SIXTY FORTY. FLORA FLORA HI
JONES SAWYER- JONES SAWYER I
REYES REYES I'D LEAVE. LEAVE I
WAS THE BILL'S. CLICK AB TWO I
DO TOO AB. TWENTY EIGHTY TWO.
FLORA FLORA HI JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER I REYES REYES I AT
LEAST. LEE I THE BILL IS OUT. I
DIDN'T THREE AB TWO ZERO ZERO
THREE FONG. FLORA FLORA HI JONES
SAWYER- JONES SAWYER I BELIEVE
LI HI THE BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
FOR AB TWO ONE EIGHT THREE STONE
. JONES SAWYER- JONES SAWYER I
REYES REYES I SEYARTO SEYARTO NO
THE BILL IS OUT. TWELFTH GRADE
NUMBER TWELVE IS ON CALL. WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE ADD ONS
LITTLE BIT LATER BUT ITEM RIGHT
NOW. WHAT THREE TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
ITEM TWELVE. ABSENT MEMBERS
REYES REYES ALL RIGHT LORD. WE
GET TO THE BILL IS OUT. NOW WE
CAN GO TO ADD ONS. NUMBER. FIVE
QUIRK AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
JONES SAWYER HI. JONES SAWYER I. THANK GOODNESS THE ITEM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS- YEAH GET OUT OF CONSENT
COUNTLESS IS THAT RIGHT NOW
CONSENT CALENDAR FLORA FLORA HI
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I'D
LEAVE. B. HI OKAY SO THAT WAS
ALREADY UP BECAUSE SERVERS THERE
ITEMS. SEVEN FLORIDA- FLORA HI
LEE HI LEE I. OKAY AND THEN ON
THE ITEM. NINE FLORIDA- FLORA HI
REYES REYES HI LEAD THE HIGH AND
THAT WAS A B. TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY. YES THEN ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE. FLORA
FLORA I REYES REYES HI LI LI I.
SOME OF THEM- THE SEVENTY SEVEN
WE HAVE OR I NEED FIFTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN SAN ITEM FIFTEEN
GARCIA. TWENTY FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE OH THREE GARCIA. FLORA. NOT
PUTTING FLORIDA NOT VOTING REYES
REYES HI LEE LEE I. M. SEVENTEEN
WE HAVE ADD ONS FOR AB SEVENTY
SEVENTY FIVE WAR. JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER HI LEE LEE I THINK
YOU. WHEN YOU ALREADY VOTED ON.
THERE IS A. HIS DOUBLE CHECK
WHICH. ONE AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN
EVERYWHERE ONLINE RIGHT OKAY AND
THEN PUT A SEVENTY WILL GIVE US
DOUBLE CHECK REYES BUILT ON
SEVENTEEN. YEAH YEAH. SO I THINK
WE'RE ALL GOOD ON A BILL TO HANG
OUT PERMANENCY ALONG THIS INTAKE
PERSON WORKING BACK. YEAH I WAS
ABLE CHECK THE CAREERS THEN
ANYBODY ELSE ONE DOUBLE CHECK
LET US KNOW ITEM ELEVEN AND
TWELVE. WE HAVE WE ARE PRAYERS.
YEP THANK YOU. NOT SURE YEAH
YEAH. ALL RIGHT SO LET'S SEE
HERE.
AS YOU. YEAH YEAH. I REMEMBER
THAT I REMEMBER YOU SAID. THAT
HAVE A LOOK AT THE STATE.
I JUST- I JUST CALLS ON THIS.
WHAT THE WORD MURDER THANK YOU.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.